can I first of all welcome everyone to
the meeting this morning to development
control committee a mid supper district
council
first of all Kyle just remind you of
some of the domestic arrangements the WC
is situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs
there's also cold water available in the
breakout area just outside by the
meeting room if the fire alarm does
sound can we please leave the meeting
room or the council chamber straight
away follow the fire exit signs and we
are to gather on the training pitch of
Ipswich Town Football Club next door and
please do not re-enter the building
until we are told it is safe to return
can I just ask everyone to double-check
that your mobiles are either switched
off or on silent there's tradition if
they ring it's a 5 Panther nation to the
Chairman's charity I'd like to remind
everyone present that the meeting will
be broadcast live today on the Internet
and will be capable of being viewed and
repeatedly viewed the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed and to
the possible use of those images and
sound recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public compress may record film or
photograph will broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded finally camembert's
and officers and police ensure that you
press the microphones for speaking and
turn off your microphones when you have
finished so just for the benefit of
members of the public there may be
people you may not have been to a
planning committee development control
committee before midst of the district
council so I'll just run through for
your benefit who's going to do what on
my right-hand side here on the front row
and myself we are the district
councillors that have been elected and
therefore will be making a decision on
the applications before us today if if
we represent the area in which the
application has come forward you have to
cross the room and sit on the other side
and you may speak on the item but may
not vote so you cannot admit Suffolk
vote on applications within your own
Ward on the top table here you have in
depresses our legal advisor
we have Gemma and
and we'll have various planning officers
from the back coming and going he'll be
presenting the applications
Jemma's the senior planning officer and
Robert Carmichael is here to make sure
that everything runs smoothly I think
that just about covers everything when
you do come up you'll come up to the
microphone on the front row you have
three minutes and it's done by an egg
timer and we do keep two three minutes
and if you go over you will be cutting
mid flow so please do keep to the three
minutes and we'll call you up and
according to the list we have so moving
on to the agenda and the first time item
item on the agenda is apologies for
absence and substitutions please we have
apologies from counselor field
councillor Mansell and councillor Turner
and today we have three substitutes of
councillor Mike Norris for counselor
field
councillor Andrew Mellon for councillor
cerumen sale and councillor Keith
Welland for council Wendy Turner thank
you very much
nice crime - to receive any declarations
of pecuniary or non pecuniary interest
by members of council Norris thank you I
do know the officer concerned on item 7e
application TC 1900 174 through Perth
serving on a committee for an access for
all project at Needham markup railway
station so I thought thought I ought to
declare that as an outside interest and
that's a non pecuniary interest thank
you thank you any other decorations nope
thank you any declarations of lobbying
of members yep which application number
7c okay thank you anyone else nope and
any declarations of personal site visit
by members nope okay the next item is
and it's in the late papers the latest
version is the confirmation the minutes
held on the meeting on the 26th of June
2019 and these appear on pages one
through two pages 12 for a page 11 and
our members have they everyone had an
opportunity she was at the meeting and
they're a fair reflection of the meeting
are you happy that I signed those
accordingly
is that agreed agreed is it yep
that's I think there are three of us
four of us then okay thank you I'll sign
there's after now we will keep that
sorry ISO number six first of all to
receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the councilors petition
scheme do we have any place none receive
chair straight onto these schedule of
planning applications we will keep the
order as in the papers but item seven a
DC 1881 46 land to the north and west of
school Road Elms law has been withdrawn
so we'll go straight on to item 7b which
is DC 1901 602 land on the north side of
Norton Road Thurston Thank You chair
good morning members ladies and
gentlemen first item on the agenda is a
reserved Metis application for 87
dwellings on land north of Norton Road
Thurston on the screen at the moment we
have a copy of the outline planning
permission you'll notice that it is a
consent for residential development up
to 200 homes and there is an Associated
section 106 agreement with the outline
and on the screen I've identified the
key clauses within that section 106
agreement at the time of considering the
outline application earlier this year
there was a master plan and that's shown
on the the right of the screen as you
can see there's a existing area of
woodland in the northeast corner a
proposed significant area of open space
to the north and then the development
itself spreads northwards from Mountain
Road on the Left running the entire
length of the western edge of the site
is Meadow Lane we'll come back to that a
little later
so in terms of the proposal before you
the reserve matters these map on the
right shows within the red boundaries
the area that you're considering today
and what you are considering is the
appearance landscaping layout and scale
of development you are not considering
access because that was resolved at
outline planning stage just to put us in
the picture the red dot is Thurston just
to the east of Barisan Edmond so it's in
the far west of the district close to
the a14 for those members who are not so
familiar with Thurston as others on that
screen I've demonstrated where some of
the key facilities are in the village so
the black star is the application site
the white dot is actually the location
of the new primary school and Suffolk
County Council is proceeding at Pace
with developing the plans for that that
site so that came out of the outline
planning permission earlier this year
the yellow dot is the Victoria public
house the blue dot is the Community
College red dot is the railway station
and there are other elements included on
that slide so the site is within walking
distance of all the key facilities in
the village in terms of the site itself
it does sit outside of the settlement
boundary for Thurston within the
existing adopted local plan but of
course it does benefit from outline
planning permission and members were
recalled that Thurston has experienced
significant deep pressure for a new
development and there are a number of
planning permissions on the books for
some 800 dwellings around the village
Thurston does benefit from having a
neighborhood plan it's one of the first
in the district to have a neighborhood
plan on the screen within the red areas
I think you'll just see ABCD other sites
that already benefit from planning
permission for residential development
so the site we're looking at is the
orange one the settlement boundary I
just highlighted there in black if you
see in terms of your emerging joint
Local Plan the site the reserve matters
he showed me the black dot and actually
now within that plan and we have to
accept that currently it has limited
weight as a planning consideration the
settlement boundary has been extended to
incorporate the whole of this site
because it now benefits from planning
finishing the neighborhood plan itself
just going back to the neighborhood plan
carries significant weight because it is
now an adopted plan so in the report
I've gone into quite a bit of detail in
terms of the parish councils objections
I've also analyzed the proposals in the
context of the neighborhood plan in the
report so in summary there is a list of
the representations from Thurston Parish
Council each of those is looked at in
detail in the report but for the sake of
comprehensiveness I've put them on the
screen so on the left you have the
outline master plan and on the right you
have the reserve Metis details that
you're being asked to consider today
the area on the right equates to that
area in green on the left so you can see
this is the first phase of a bigger
development if this proposal is
successful this morning future phases
will follow quickly because the
applicant is keen to build this scheme
out which is important in terms of
delivery and we'll come on to that a
little bit later so just to reinforce
the pale green on the left is the area
that we're looking at this morning the
details are shown on the right we will
go into a bit more detail in terms of
what that layout shows here's the site
if we superimpose the reserved matters
onto that era I would like you to take a
little bit of time to look at it as you
go out Meadow Lane which is the road
that runs north-south you'll see a
cluster of existing properties now we've
been very careful to ensure that the
reserve matters before you have little
or no effect on the residential amenity
of those properties and I will explain
why in a moment
so at the southern end of the site
because I can't fit all of the
development on one so I will do it in
two halves each of those properties has
an elevation that looks towards the road
where we have a walk ordinarily might be
a blank flank and elevation the
developer has provided elevations to
that so it isn't a blank flank and
overlooking this little area of green we
are going to secure additional
elevational changes so in terms of
interest there are no blank flanks
looking out onto public space we
followed the same principle with the
northern end of this
lay out in terms of the estate now you
remember that access was agreed at
outline stage we have two points of
access the principal Street in the dark
blue which will also serve the new
primary school we have a secondary
access which is the lighter blue Suffolk
County Council of Highway Authority were
perfectly happy with this arrangement
ultimately the dark blue and the light
blue will link up in a loop serving the
whole estate in terms of connectivity
what I've highlighted on the left are
the areas where we have speed tables if
you look at the area B on the right what
we've done is introduced a
pedestrian-friendly connection from
within the estate through to the new
primary school and that does cross a
speed table so what we've been trying to
do is reinforce safe routes to school
with our colleagues at Suffolk County
Council again that shows in greater
detail the connectivity so you can
easily get into the countryside with at
least three connections to Meadow Lane
there pedestrian connections we don't
have any vascular connections to Meadow
Lane
we have footpath connections along the
frontage of the site and as you can see
from the report we have secured from
Linden homes an additional sixty five
thousand pounds to provide Footwear on
the southern side of Norton Road in
front of the Victoria public house that
now means anyone within the village can
walk to the primary school on a foot way
which at the moment you can't always do
and the 106 that has already been
secured provides for a pedestrian
crossing on there I've shown its
position illustratively with a pink
arrow so in terms of safe routes to
school this site through with the
details will deliver a safe route to the
new primary school from day one which we
think is a significant benefit
in terms of story Heights and you'll
notice that the parish council were
concerned about the two and a half story
but it's looking at more detail so
everything in red is two-story
everything in blue is bungalow and you
recall earlier I asked you to note the
cluster of houses the existing houses on
Meadow Lane each of those is opposite an
existing property so there isn't there
is nothing above bungalow height where
there is any relationship to existing
dwellings we feel that that is a an
excellent way to harmonize new and
existing in terms of residential amenity
what I didn't demonstrate there is
obviously the gray area the Crescent and
there's one property on the frontage
it's two and a half story now we often
have debates that committee what does
two and a half story mean is it really
three stories disguised as something
else what does it actually mean
we I'll show you in a little bit more
detail because I'm convinced but the two
plus attic stories will not stand out
within this development in terms of the
scale and mass in terms of parking the
dominant feature the centerpiece is the
Crescent that has its own parking on a
hard surface we have had a comment from
Suffolk County Council in terms of some
of the parking space within the
secondary street every blue dot on the
right is a parking space the majority
are all within residential curtilage but
what we have tried here is something a
little bit different it works I've seen
it working other parts of East Anglia
within new estates and it works well
you'll notice that on this extract there
are two spaces in a little lay by within
the street and what that actually does
is rather than have the 2.25 to 0.25 for
visitors on plot what we've actually
done is pull out the visitor space and
put it on the highway so it's available
for any visitor and that way you
a much more efficient use of visitor
spaces but they're not conveyed to
individual properties so there are more
visitor spaces available to more people
each of those has at least two on-site
parking spaces some have garages you'll
notice that the Parish Council we're a
little bit concerned that not every plot
had a garage but I'll say in the report
your standards do not require a garage
on every plot it simply requires parking
spaces so we're perfectly satisfied with
that arrangement
I think the County Council is a little
bit nervous about the idea of having
parking on the street in a lay-by but in
many ways that's a better use of the
space because it isn't obstructing
traffic that wishes to usually the road
if we actually had parking on the street
without the lay-by that reduces the
width of the carriage rate this doesn't
reduce the width of the carriageway
in terms of the parish councils come in
so they were concerned that the
development might not reflect the
character of properties within the
village so what I've done is taken a
series of pictures of estates in the
immediate vicinity obviously there is
nothing in this estate that would look
like the old traditional properties that
you find in first but the majority of
the properties around it are modern so
here we have clover fields
there's the pub the other side of Norton
Road in some ways this is one of the
least attractive I don't mean to be rude
to the occupies it's not their fault
that the scheme has a a place boarded
fence along the entire frontage on the
south side and blank elevations but what
we've achieved on the other side I would
say is superior in terms of urban design
and here we have sand pit lane again
modern properties so what are we looking
at on this site you remember I was
describing how corner turning units have
been secured with elevations on flank
ends here's an example
so the house on the left is what you
would see from the main bit of frontage
but the picture on the right is actually
the end elevation of that property so it
has a bay window in this example blind
window and actually there's an elevation
that then runs at 90 degrees along the
adjacent streets that's a fully elevated
corner which is far more interesting
than seeing lots of blank blank walls
and we've got that throughout this phase
of development again here's another one
we're on a corner where you have right
angled development there are no blank
flank and wall so it's always something
of interest to to look at even the
bungalows we've worked hard with linden
homes to do something a little bit out
of the ordinary rather it just be a
straight box with a huge roof a lid
we've actually got some rather elegant
bay windows the porch it helps to add
interest to something is often an
afterthought in terms of bungalows very
little thought ever goes into design the
bungalows so I'm pleased that linden
homes have really worked with us to
start developing a bungalow style that
has something a little special about it
a very ordinary Terrace but look at the
detail we've got the flat brick arches
we've got the porches we have nicely
proportioned casement windows that is a
I would say almost a traditional village
star terrace in a modern idiom so we're
very pleased with that
and again look at those there's always a
bit of interest this and crippled Eve's
we've got bay windows again the detail
we've have window reveals external
glazing bars we've also encouraged
linden to use a range of materials into
clay tiles the artificial slate of the
ones that you have recently seen on
others estates that you like not the
concrete nasties and again this is
another estate where we can say the
design bar is being raised from the
the average that perhaps we see across
East Anglia in terms of the Crescent I
think the the parish councils a little
concerned well they may be significantly
concerned I don't want to underestimate
their their concern this is an urban
featuring and in some ways they are
entirely right but what we have here is
a significant estate it isn't any longer
or it won't be rural area and this
actually forms the centerpiece and I
think when you look at the following
slides I'm hoping that your feel it's a
rather attractive composition it isn't
bath
it can't be bath but it's it's the first
step we've had at introducing something
a little bit different into the town
scape that is not an unattractive
arrangement of properties we got on this
case it's simple render casements
steeply pitched roof I want you to pay
particular attention to the dormer
windows because you recall that the
parish would concern that two-story Plus
attic would look out of character and
what we've done is through working with
linden we have secured much smaller
dormers and I think the parish council
were right because in some ways because
when the scheme first came in they were
much bigger dormer windows but I think
you would have to agree that they sit
nicely within the roof they are minor
incidents in the roof they're no longer
massive dolmas that sort of make the
thing look top-heavy that's a rather
elegant composition what we've also
secured and it's not shown on that slide
is rather than have a single chimney
between the properties we're getting a
double stack to make it look far more
authentic so that that will be a wider
chimney stack with two putts it'll be a
false chimney but it will look - all
intended purpose like a fully
functioning chimney
there it is in in flat 2d form but you
can't really get from that is the effect
of the Crescent so what we've done is I
quickly knocked up a model and then we
took a photograph of it so that's how it
might look but of course that
centerpiece of Greene will have planting
so let's add some some planting that
really begins to look like a rather
elegant feature within the center of
this part of the estate because it's in
the center it doesn't necessarily impact
the rest of Thurston but its own little
hidden hidden gem so if you have a need
to go into the estate I think that would
be quite an attractive feature to pass
in terms of what it might feel like
hopefully nothing happens in terms of
the sounds of the goofiness
that's quite a elegant feature and again
that centerpiece will be landscaped just
to emphasize the point of the dormers on
the left we have the original house type
with the bigger dormer and on the right
we have the amended I think if I just
press that what you see then very
quickly you can see the significant
difference now in terms of is a
two-story plus attic building any higher
than a two-story the answer is is there
so on the Left we have the Pembroke
house type and on the right we have the
Ripley the ridge height is exactly the
same so whilst I have some sympathy for
the parish council in terms of their
pointers is a two and a half story
building out of character I would have
to say physically there is no real
difference therefore it won't have an
adverse impact residential amenity we've
already looked at the point if in terms
of properties in Meadow Lane but just to
reinforce that so you can see them in
juxtaposition there we go
so we're perfectly satisfied there are
no harmful impacts on residential
amenity and on the South we only have
the Victoria pub to think about in terms
of impact as the shots down Meadow Lane
the site is on the left that hedge will
remain intact
now the properties in Meadow Lane you'll
see there is already an established
hedgerow along the eastern side of
Meadow Lane the parish council and
residents of absolutely keen it's
probably not the right word but they've
asked us to ensure that hedgerows
protected what we've done is we've
actually worked with linden to reinforce
it so rather than just protect it we are
going to beef that hedge up we've seen
the bungalows but but the time you have
that hedge and that's only at two meters
high so assuming it was trimmed say the
farmer went down there with the flail
and just took it down to two meters you
will see very little of those but if
they're left to just grow naturally they
will soon disappear in terms of the
impact on Meadow Lane all the BIM
collection points have been carefully
worked out they all satisfy our
standards so every bin can be collected
by our teams
there will be no rubbish left and
collected they're all within the
prescribed walking distance the dust
cart
that's the Victoria table at the bottom
of the shot the site opens up to the
north there it is again
in terms of landscaping and this is
something the parish council working to
ensure that we got right is so on the
norton road frontage we have typical
field edge species so we have that that
classic mixture of field maple dogwood
hazel or someone's spindle and black
thorn and that also extends for that's
where we're reinforcing the planting all
the way up meadow meadow line so this is
exactly the sort of planting you would
expect to see in a rural setting this
will help to maintain the character of
the frontage
so again here's some being country folk
you will know what they all all look
like but in terms of ecology that
provides a fantastic larder for for
wildlife and that's something that the
parish wanted us to be sure that we
achieve is actually not only to have
excellent landscaping but to ensure that
it contributes towards biodiversity so
here's a classic shot of the flowers of
a spindle tree you can see throughout
this the landscapers
not only thought about food for wildlife
they thought about seasonal color and
they've thought about ensuring that it
harmonizes with a rural setting outside
of the application layer just to
demonstrate to members that drainage has
been properly considered within the open
space at the north of the site is is a
pond that will receive surface water and
that has the capacity to take abnormal
or extraordinary extreme weather events
when it isn't functioning as effectively
a balancing pond it will be part of the
public open space
so there there is the pond in the top
right-hand corner that's the bit of the
estate road that we'll take in Phase two
so this this morning you'll be also
being asked to consider that section of
road we are satisfied that a perfectly
acceptable form of townscape can be
developed around that that highway
network in terms of it additional
drainage points the Suffolk County
Council's floods and Water Authority are
satisfied with the proposal but they
have asked us to add three additional
conditions which we're perfectly
satisfied are are appropriate they're
dealing with some technical drainage
matters it won't affect the details that
you see before you so all in all we
think this is an excellent scheme we
have suggested that you might want to
defer to the head of the acting chief
planning officer in order that we can
secure a legal agreement to make sure we
get the additional sixty five thousand
for but other than that we think this is
a scheme that we wholeheartedly commend
to the committee thank you very much for
that comprehensive overview of the
application any questions at this point
from members yeah council even Thank You
chair I was just wanting if you could um
confirm the status of thirst and
neighborhood plan because I understand
it's not going to referendum until
September therefore isn't yet made or
adopted and so can you confirm kind of
what status we can give that with
regards this application and also
there's been mention in the papers about
a play area specifically reference to a
junior play area could you just explain
that because I you haven't mentioned it
in your presentation thank you I'm
grateful to you council ebin because I
did say had been adopted and you're
quite
it hasn't what has happened is it has
been submitted and therefore carries
significant but not actually dominant
weight so thank you for the correction
we are expecting it to go to referendum
later this this year and depending on
the outcome of that and we will either
have ultimate leaf once it's gone to
full council and adopted neighborhood
plan or not so I apologize to the
committee for any misleading I I did
through that earlier statement in terms
of the plate area that will follow is
the second phase that area to the north
of that I wonder if my colleague a could
with us back to let's say slide for
apologies for the I'm just gonna quickly
flick
yeah
so within that area of open space on the
right hand side the green that is where
the play area will be provided in some
ways you could argue it's unfortunate
it's not available in the first phase
but experience is tended to show if you
have a junior play area in what is a
development site it tends not to be used
for the obvious purpose of obvious
reason that people don't think it's
necessarily safe for kids to be playing
out while there are construction
vehicles moving about so it will happen
at the later phases but it is secured
through the section one OC so it isn't
something that will slip through the net
or be forgotten and the other question
is that yeah castle Willam I think you
chair um I've got several questions the
first is on slide 17 about the shared
surface there is a shared surface which
is more or less on the junction I'm just
a bit concerned that when vehicles might
turn into the secondary road they will
be confronted by pedestrians walking on
a shared surface I think we need to make
sure that Suffolk County Council are
happy with that although it's a
secondary secondary road once a loop
people are going to use them up the road
that's most convenient I'd say we're
straying into survey yeah so we are we
yeah the reason that I'm asking the
question is are we sure that current
accounts are happy with that and there
are a few other comments that the county
made have they all been taken into
account or is that wrapped up in a
condition
if I'm afraid we gonna have to do a
little bit of slide jiggling but castle
well erm you referred to slide 17 do
slide 17 I understand the point you make
absolutely now if I described it as a
share to surface in some ways that is
true but technically that is a raised or
I did say race PT words on them and that
is slightly different so we can't really
assume in so you're talking about the
area ie yeah you'll notice that there
are footpaths that take you further into
the development so we're encouraging
pedestrians to get into the site to
cross but that is in some ways it's no
different to any other Junction you'll
notice that the primary footpath runs
along the front there will be the
dropped curb pedestrians will be
crossing east to west at that junction
point we're not necessarily advocating
that pedestrians are crossing the whole
way along that flat surface but what it
does to drivers because there will be a
ramp at either end is say to them
because you're now hitting this ramp you
are going through a residential area we
want you to slow down so it certainly
does provide a crossing point at
adjacent to the primary school and in
some ways that is where pedestrians will
be crossing but and that's where they're
being encouraged across but it's much
further into the estate so Suffolk
County Council are absolutely happy with
the arrangement
they helped negotiate that geometry that
data so I can absolutely confirm there
they're happy in terms of their other
comments the only outstanding issue they
have is with the labels as I explained
in all other respects they are satisfied
sorry I've got two or three others yeah
the next one is about the balancing pond
do we know what the arrangements for
maintenance are and is the internal
drainage board aware of it because there
may be a commuted some payable to the
internal drainage board are they aware
the actual pond is outside of the
reserve matters that you're looking at
this morning what I've done is put it in
there to demonstrate that we haven't
forgotten the whole issue of drainage
ultimately all of that will be sorted
out in terms of the adoption and that's
down to Suffolk County Council and
others that will all be resolved and I'm
sure you will get those details in the
next phase so that will be dealt with my
last one is very simple did you say it's
a pelican crossing or a zebra crossing
of the road front to the side I left
that open I didn't say one all the the
other that is down to Suffolk County
counselors Highway Authority you might
suggest that in your view something you
can activate would be preferable to
something that you rely on it and the
driver stopping so you might prefer a
pelican to a zebra you're perfectly able
as a committee to ask the county to
consider that when they are thinking
about the type of crossing they will be
installing but it isn't a matter for
this committee or this application but
perfectly understandable coming thank
you first any other custom stuff at
council can't work establish there are
several comments regarding security I
can confirm that these were taken into
account in the net yes
in terms of the conditions there are
some conditions where we've required the
height of balls to be raised but
generally speaking we are very satisfied
but this is a safe in terms of designing
out crime state some of the comments
made by the police we've acted on
unsecured amendments so we're now
satisfied that it it takes them the
right boxes in terms of security okay
thank you no more questions so we'll
move on to the speakers from the public
and from parish councillor so first up
is Victoria locals from the parish
council if you'd like to come up and we
have a time here and if you can keep for
three minutes please
firstly the Parish Council notes and is
pleased to accept that the lay out
before the committee is a vast
improvement on that which was first
submitted and thanks planning offices
and linden homes for their commitment to
negotiation in principle the parish
council does support this application it
does however have some concerns that he
would like to voice individual
councilors and myself as Clark visited
sites in fact study from Walden Royston
Malden and Braintree I've spoken
extensively to my colleague Clark's at
both that stirred and serf from Walden
and it has to be noted that those
designs were all off towns and whilst
the design layout and materials might be
the best suited to a town they may not
be best suited to a site that sits on
the edge of a rural village we are
concerned at the 2.5 storey dwellings
however we would like to say that whilst
we might have to accept those in the
Crescent which have had the mock dormice
remodel to ensure that the profile of
the roof is more in keeping with the
remainder of the dwellings it is
sincerely hoped that these would not be
replicated within the remainder of the
site coming forward under further
reserved matters as we do not feel their
design is compatible with the actual
location of this site the PC does take
issue that linden homes and your own
Planning Officers have not sought to
consider insuring all properties are
built to the National leda's I described
space standards and not just those of
affordable ranked tenure and it is noted
under sections of the report section 70
that not all meet this standard in the
affordable housing connectivity the
Parish Council recognizes and is
appreciative that linden holmes has
offered an additional contribution
thereby increasing the content activity
to and from the site as well as within
the site and access to the primary
school however given that most accesing
the primary school and preschool will be
from the south it does take issue that a
zebra crossing is decided on Norton Road
and would have liked to have seen this
upgraded to a pedestrian light
controlled crossing which will ensure
that motorists approach the area with
care with the intention of stopping
should it become necessary well snow
teen that this phase does not provide
plated provision and there is a desire
to enhance design quality in its future
in its open spaces
it should be noted that PC is expecting
a future provision of play provision to
complement and enhance existing
provision within the village and meet
any known deficits therefore there is a
real expectation that linden homes will
actively engage with the Parish Council
prior to the submission of reserved
matters for other sections of this site
there is a need for adventure-style
provision attractive to juniors and
other children which were complement and
enhance the wooded areas of this site
the Parish Council was very pleased to
see that the hetero Long Meadow Lane is
being maintained and will enhance the
area and finally with regards to cite a
specific construction management scheme
this does require careful consideration
give the development to the south of
Norton Road and to the west of Norton
Road all are due to commence at the same
time there will be a plethora of
construction vehicles within the village
thank you very much okay do you have any
questions talk to the parish council
associate counsel you've been Thank You
chair I'm Chris ask how this fits with
your neighborhood plan please so I help
how does this site fit within your
neighborhood plan overall yes we are I
mean obviously it is outside our
built-up area boundary but our
neighbourhood plan has now we've drawn
its boundary this does sit within and
this face does come we are happy that
this phase apart from two point five
storey dwellings does conform thank you
any other questions no thank you very
much thank you
next up we have Lydia voice who's the
applicant or agent
and again if you can keep the three
minutes please I've just got the key
with me if you have any questions that
I'm unable to answer okay thank you good
morning my name is Lydia bias from
Savile's agent to Lyndon Holmes we
support the officers recommendation for
approval for the reserved matters for
the first phase of residential
development a land north of north
immersed and linden homes is a national
house builder with a focus on delivering
well-designed and sustainable new homes
their achievements have been recognized
through a receipt of numerous awards
including silver in what house Awards
sustainable developer category in 2016
Linden Homes is keen to bring forward
new homes within mid Suffolk as
explained by your officer the principle
of residential development including the
number of dwellings at the site were
established through the outlined
Planning Commission matters for your
consideration our appearance scale
layout and landscaping the design
principles of the reserve matters the
mission positively respond to the
opportunities of the site full
consideration is given to the
integration of the site with the new
primary school the village of Thurston
whilst achieving sustainable benefits
for new and existing residents whilst
access is not a matter for consideration
at this stage it should be noted that
approval of this first reserve matter as
mission will enable the timely
construction of both the access to serve
the residential development and the new
primary school which was approved as
part of the outlined consent linen
Holmes has agreed to provide an
additional financial contribution of
sixty-five thousand pounds to Suffolk
County Council to assist in the
provision of a new public four-way
linking person to the new primary school
the first phase of residential
development will bring forward 87 new
homes in a mix of sizes ranging from one
bed to five bedroom properties including
30 affordable homes which is 35 percent
affordable policy compliant the scheme
incorporates 11 bungalows along the
western edge of the site the mix of
house in
proposed reflects the accommodation
needs of different people and age groups
to achieve a mixed balanced and cohesive
community the applicant has worked
closely with the local planning
authority and technical console T's as
part of pre-application discussions and
throughout the course of the application
to respond to comments received as is it
as it is acknowledged that the parish
council raised concerns about various
aspects of the proposals which your
planning officer has responded to in
detail within the report to committee
and the presentation the plans were of
who will reflect the council's policy
requirements and it has been
acknowledged by officer that linden
Holmes has taken the opportunity to
promote a higher quality development the
majority of her hedgerows and trees will
be retained and additional planting is
proposed throughout the site to areas of
public open space are incorporated into
this first phase of development linden
Holmes has designed the specification of
the new homes to achieve high levels of
fabric energy efficiency and is also
proposing the provision of electric
vehicle or charging points within
garages I'm afraid of three minutes is
up so actually the last sentences have
one final sentence to summarize but it
is one sentence and ok so in addition to
the legal agreements and still payments
we wish the that you can support your
officers recommendation for approval
thank you thank you very much do we have
any questions lots of hands going up we
start on the same cows are having in the
parish clerk said something about the
minimum space stands for not all the
houses yes so um this isn't a policy
requirement within miss Suffolk the
National described space Sanders we have
worked with the affordable ten years
so the affordable rent properties will
meet that um Stan
but as set out within the committee
report and we've set out this floorspace
schedule of what the variance is and we
don't think it's significantly different
and similar you mentioned electrical
charging points for vehicles is this
gonna be on every property or just a
limited number of properties within the
garage properties only stage again this
is a requirement but we lived in homes
have worked together with the council to
secure this cute and there was another
hand further along yeah councillor well
thank you chair and could you clarify
which properties are to be affordable
homes and which properties are to have a
rendered finish and what palette of
colors you're using for the rendering
please the submitter plans do identify
which properties will be affordable
they're identified with spots on the
plans I don't have them before me to
show you um come page one to seven of
the papers slide 11 is it slide 11 or
was it slide 12 please have a get that
put that one up
it's a little bit difficult to see but
it's on the western edge and on the
eastern edge as well to the south and
indicated with the dots on him and again
this is shown in the illustrative
materials plan so that it's going to be
shown you know a mixture throughout the
site we haven't specified the specific
details at this stage but we've
indicated color ranges supreme yeah it's
basically creams and creams and whites
yeah thank you any other questions No
thank you very much thank you I'm just
kind of sauce one quick question
actually you've heard the parish council
talk about the player and everything I
mean that's outside of this phase really
but I mean will you be carrying out
negotiations going so we will go and
discuss the equipment and we've had
discussions about thank you
thank you for the reassurance okay
members say and we've had every we now
move on to the ward members now I've had
one board member comment filed somewhere
safe
[Applause]
ah hey Richard nice alright so and we
their two board members
there's counsel Harry Richland the
counselor counselor Wendy the throne
counsel Wendy Turner I've just have
comment from a counselor how Richardson
which I will read out unfortunately
unable to attend in person so would like
to submit the comments below whilst I do
not subject to this reserved matters
application on the whole and largely
agree with the recommendation made by
officers I'd like to express
disappointments about two particular
aspects firstly I'm disappointed to see
that this application includes two and a
half story buildings and numerous
locations which are not in keeping with
the design of the existing dwellings in
the northern part of person which has
already been noted by both officers and
the parish council although these are
deemed to be acceptable by officers I
believe this would represent
unacceptable deviation from the existing
character of the settlement and hope
these can be admitted from the proposed
development by condition or by
negotiation with officers secondly I
recognize the proposed density of the
development might represent a
distinctively urban layout and hope the
committee will reinforce officers
recommendations that the subsequent
phases of development are at a lower
density to represent the rural
characteristics of the surrounding area
aside from those concerns I am satisfied
with the assurances received by the
planning officers in relation to the
issues raised by the parish council so
would advocate for approval of this
application along with necessary
conditions as from council hairy roots
so members that's all the information
provided to us we've had a full
presentation we've heard from the parish
council and we've heard from the
applicant and the ward one of the ward
members over to you to discuss debate
and we need to reach a conclusion yes
casa milà Jeff is it possible where
there seems to be some obviously
criticism of the actual two and a half
story they could have like the windows
flapped within the roof you often see so
you've got I've still got room in the
roof but I said having like the expert
on the top it's flush with the actual
roof tour what I'll do is let's just get
clarity on what we can I can't change
and just so we have a clarity about
because the strengh and we all may have
very different personal views and we
could all could get around the round
circle so that's just how character and
what we can or can't comment on so we
support in front of us if there are
reasons that you would consider refusal
but there are things that we could go
away and amend rather than outright
refuse perhaps that might be an area we
could look at
yes potentially changing windows
changing various things on these
properties is an option but if that is
something that would be reason to refuse
will be out of character rather than a
personal preference or design designee
is always very subjective and is
something that we have struggled with
appeal all before and you know probably
justifies a note of caution on that
unless the committee felt particularly
strongly that that would be absolutely
out of character and then perhaps
whether we would have them authority to
go and review that would be probably
what I would suggest thank you for that
thank you for that
well no one's starting I yes I didn't
like to go first because I don't want to
lead the conversation so counsel well um
thank you Jeff
I haven't made up my mind on this one I
could see I could see that there's been
a lot of discussion and some of the
discussion has led to compromise which
is to be commended and I would like to
talk a little bit about whether we
should have a pelican or whether we
should ask for a pelican or a zebra
crossing and I just put these few ideas
into people's minds one of the dangers
of a pelican crossing in that location
is a pelican crossing makes a noise
every time somebody pushes the button it
goes pip pip pip and I'm not sure that
this would be the right location for
that however if that's what we wanted
then we ought to ask for it to be
designed to the standards that help
those who are hard of hearing and people
who have sight difficulties and there
are ways of doing that with a rotating
knob or whatever so I think we need to
be mindful if we're going to ask for a
pelican or we ought to think about how
it's going to be used who can use it and
what the noise is going to be I'm
concerned about the balancing pond I see
we're going to leave that until later
but it's got to be constructed I guess
as part of phase 1 so we need to make
sure that it is going to be well
protected and maintained for the whole
duration of the construction period of
this phase and subsequent phases and
away into the future so those are my two
my other concern obviously was the
shared surface just inside the the
junction but I understood what the
officer is said I mean I'm generally
generally happy with the way that the
negotiations have gone just got those
three points that I'm still mulling over
council even
Thank You Tara I'm not sure which price
guard this were at the moment I've got
several concerns with regards to this
overall the urban feel I've got concern
about in the village of Emma Thurston's
growing village and I'm just wondering
whether greater emphasis on the
landscaping particularly with native
planting might help that I'm not sure
that the conditions actually kind of
give us enough confidence in that also
I've got concern about space standards I
think we should be conforming to
national standards on on that and I
think this this site should and there's
also the concerns I note from the
questioning earlier I also had a point
about the safety issues that the police
have raised and with regards to to kind
of have the design of parking and so on
and again I'm not sure that that's met
within the conditions and finally the
last condition relates to having
external electrical connection so if
that can be for the vehicle charging as
well because there aren't that many
garages there aren't that many garages
so that if you know by the Thomases
built out there's gonna be a lot of
electric cars and I think we need to
kind of be considering that I think
that's what that condition means but
we'll just get clarity on that in
regarding space standards can we just
have clarity about what is within the
mid Suffolk remit on that currently you
do not have a policy that requires any
internal space standard
now as southern management officers we
have made representation to our policy
colleagues that we have an ideal
opportunity to incorporate them into the
new local plan the government advocates
that that is the place to put your space
standards so what we try and do is we
try and encourage developers to meet the
national standards but we cannot require
them to do so and on this occasion we
are fortunate insofar as Linton Holmes
have ensure that the affordable housing
does meet the the standard but you're
quite right not all of the open market
units will meet the nationally described
space standards there isn't anything we
can do in terms of having a policy to
force them to do that if I could just
come back on that point my understanding
is in the emerging joint local plan we
have got we have we have got something
about space standards in in that - Bret
um so I think that we should be kind of
pushing for that as much as possible I
can assure council ebin that there's
officers we are pushing but currently if
a developer says and what weight can the
playing authority give the emerging
local plan we have to say very limited
however as it progresses hopefully we're
in a much stronger position in terms of
some the other points you've you've
raised we have added that condition on
external connection points for the very
reason that you have highlighted there
are very few garages so it's not much of
an offer to say that we'll have them in
the garages when the majority of the
stock plots don't have a garage so we're
requiring at least some sort of external
point electrical connection
so that were somebody to buy an electric
vehicle they wouldn't then have to start
thinking about running the juice around
the side of the building to a point that
we think that is important I would
accept your your point in terms of an
urban feel having an outline planning
permission
approved for up to 200 darlings almost
certainly means that they will not have
the character of a traditional village
for that to happen it would have to be
at densities much lower than the
government would ever advocate so
unfortunately I don't think we're ever
gonna see something you would say was
characteristically village feel but what
we can do is ensure that the house types
have references to rural elements and
the materials we've tried to do in this
occasion we have secured amendments
within the layout to satisfy the
concerns expressed by the police when we
have additional conditions to ensure
that they are delivered terms of
councillor Willems point I don't see why
there couldn't be discussion between
members and the County Council in terms
of the crossing as I said before it's
not something we can deal with here but
I understand all the points you're
making I'm quite happy to make
representations to our colleagues at
Suffolk County that it may be they if
you have a particular interest in that
we can certainly the board members we
can never and the parish council we can
have a discussion around what is the
best solution I think they would be keen
to to be involved in that I think that's
all I would say in terms of your your
points council of women because we've
taken with the others I think in so
that's my thank you
yep you go next cowgirl after you um I
think my only worry is the space Sanders
but as we haven't actually got one of
our own policies to cover that you know
I think it's very good um you know that
they've really improved the overall plan
they've listened to people they've
engaged with the village and the parish
council I think you know I'm usually you
know thinking a lot of these signs that
I people I think they've done well you
know although I've recognized that the
parish council has concerns about the
dermal winders I actually think that's a
better look than sort of a skylight or
Velux window and and I'm happy to go
with the account the officers
recommendation that
to approve this are you looking to
propose that thank you for that I'll go
next to them because you've already been
if I may and then bring you back in and
yeah I mean it's interesting one isn't
it because I mean can well done to the
parish council in Lindon house because
clear you've got together and achieved a
lot with officers and bringing it
forward but it's just in the parish
councils perspective just not quite over
the edge yet but it's very close it
feels like and it fits within the
neighborhood plans so you know there it
takes so many of the boxes that we often
don't see ticked actually here so I
think that's fantastic if we could just
overcome the two and a half story which
is clearly one of the remaining hurdles
but I think what's before us is such a
marked improvement I don't think we can
turn it from my perspective I don't
think I could vote against it just on
the two-and-a-half story but what I
would say is the the applicants here and
the message is loud and clear for the
next phase so I think if you can please
have more discussions ongoing
discussions through the next phase with
the parish council and hopefully try and
take account of what's being said but I
can't find a reason to refuse it but
it's not 100% perfect as where I sit
councillor Mullen I must have it I must
concur with cash like adding them and
councillor Hicks I am impressed with the
amount of work it's been going on
between the planning authority the
parish council and Lyndon Holmes I think
that that's really good and shooting
encouraged that to go on in the future
I'm particularly impressed with some of
the things that have been taking place
with making sure the roads are
particularly safe
you've got the footpath going to the
proposed primary school the fatty
restaurant bungalows we always hear I
hear a lot of reports people saying
there's not enough bungalows of people
also one beds in the affordable housing
people may want to downsize I think
that's a very positive move and if you
have that I would like to second the
proposal for approval thank you
how sonorous yes yes thank you
unbalanced I'm inclined to support the
recommendation I just do have one
question actually for the officer if I
may on the layout on the site layout on
slide in Devon there is a lot of the
access roads are shown as shared
surfaces are these surfaces suitable for
access by emergency vehicles in the case
of fire or whatever thank you
yes they are can't cuss even Thank You
chair I think if we're moving towards a
decision could we just make sure in the
condition that we're it's got ecological
enhancement details can someone explain
what that's going to cover because a
little bit woolly to me and I think we
want to make sure got native planting in
there that there's sufficient
landscaping Detroiter as I said before
to you know bring that up and feel more
towards of a village type feel
someone just qualify that please thank
you
I have to apologize akin to counselor
even insofar as this application is
accompanied by a raft of supporting
documents which includes an ecological
strategy what I've done for the purpose
of this report is shorthand to say
provided they implement everything in
that strategy we are satisfied and I can
say that with certainty because the
advice from place services our
consultants in terms of ecology they are
perfectly happy with all the measures
that are being proposed
it's simply I didn't set them all down
in the report so that even goes down to
things like hedgehog openings in all the
fences between properties so there is a
whole raft what we're saying by that
condition you must now implement the
scheme in accordance with their
supporting document that's how we secure
there in native species that's how we
sure that the box is the hijab rule in
this we are satisfied thank you thank
you
yeah cancer welcome Thank You chair I'm
just one small concern which I think you
can take into account when you're having
the discussions about the landscaping
and that is there are a lot of very
small areas of grass grass areas which
will come into some sort of guests come
into some sort of maintenance agreement
I'm just a little bit worried that they
are so small areas and there's so many
of them they will they will be difficult
to maintain if there is a way of making
sure that there's got to be a purpose to
all these little tiny bits of grass if
there is no purpose for them please
don't put lots and lots of little bits
of grass in because you can't leave
anything else to do with it that's a
plate of the fleet of the developer as
much as to the offices thank you for
that okay so we're gonna go to a vote
it's been proposed by Councillor having
them and seconded by Councillor miller
as per the recommendation on page one
one five and one one six of our papers
actually yeah those are the latest
version of the recommendation with the
conditions version can you just run
through the extra conditions for it's
just so 100% clear three conditions from
Suffolk County Council floods and water
that I had on the penultimate slide of
them yeah that's all from the floods
team sir all those in favor of the
recommendation as laid out can we have a
show of hands please that's unanimous
thank you very much
[Applause]
we'll now move on to item 7c in the
agenda which is application number
th9001 5 5 4 which is outline planning
permission in bad WA ash and Carson
mayor would sit on the other side of the
room for this and be able to comment but
not fade
yes okay over to Alex Scott to present
Thank You chairman this is item 7c in
the papers application reference DC 1901
double v for is land off Hunstanton Road
bad will ash it's an outline application
with all matters reserved safer access
the erection of fifty-two dwellings
including 18 affordable dwellings the
creation of a new estate access to
Hunstanton Road the application follows
prior application reference DC 18 double
zero four six five four a similar
development which was refused by
committee be in November of 2018 for the
reasons that act in part one of your
papers and this current application
seeks to overcome these prior reasons
given for refusal so to the presentation
this is a general site location in the
immediate area you can see
okay
yeah just for the town's for reference
here very soon Edmunds stowed market and
up to this this is a aerial map of the
the wider area have the villagers bad
well ash in this location and the
designs outlined in red and this is a
close-up aerial view again this is the
site location and excuse me on to some
constraints the existing settlement
boundary in the development plan is
outlined here in purple and the color
coding indicates a primary village which
is the second order village it has quite
a few service and services and
facilities as outlined in the report but
not the maximum which are enjoyed by our
key service centres the public footpath
the formal route commences here on
Hunstanton Road and continues adjacent
to the northwest of a site and emerging
onto onto the southern road in that
location and part of the application is
to redefine this formal route the
initial point is rather overgrown and
there are more informal haphazard routes
used by members of the public which
wonder all over the applicant site so to
redefine that that formal route is a
benefit of the proposal
and on this slide we can also see the
flood zones the Environment Agency flood
zones two and three to the south of the
site here and as we can see the
application site lies outside zones so
onto more constraints and the black
hatched area indicates potentially
contaminated land with reference to the
site's previous use of the gravel
extraction and as referred to in the
report comprehensive land contamination
assessment has been that's submitted
with the application and that has been
assessed by your environmental
protection officers who are satisfied
that future occupants would not be in
any danger from sources of land
contamination this is a existing
topographical survey of the existing
sites and the contours denote the
highest point of a site would be in this
location in the northeast corner and it
also highlights the survey trees in
green and the location of the existing
lake within the center of the site yeah
this is the dicket ofwhat plan shall be
pointed out that this is indicative at
this stage say for the access point
which is located here on to constant
road and that is adjacent to the site of
the formalized route of the public
right-of-way now the location for the
access has been selected as the point
which will maximize visibility so we
have the the road curving away in this
location and then again in this location
maximizes visibility in both locations
which would be more more restricted if
it were further down here as you get to
about that point so that that's the best
the general reason for the selection of
the access point the existing vegetation
trees have been retained in this
location and here and a area of public
open space and a wildlife pond are
proposed between the houses and the ham
stone road frontage the speed limit of
the highway to the frontage is 30 miles
an hour just to confirm that and that
commences just off the page the junction
as you head into the village from the
east a large amount of landscaping and
tree planting is also proposed to the
existing open areas to the south and
north east and a large attenuation pond
to deal with surface water drainage as
proposed and please note that is
separate to the existing lake which
would be adjacent to the south of that
this is the detail of the proposed
estate road access showing visibility
splays which have been accepted by the
County Highways Authority as being safe
and the yellow areas denote proposed
paved footpaths away from the metal
carriageway with the ability to connect
into the existing a footpath network of
the village along the area of the
visibility displays which should remain
clear in this location next we have the
proposed surface water drainage plan to
the attenuation Basin so it will link in
through the proposed access roads to the
attenuation Basin in this location and
this has been assessed by the local lead
flood authority of the County Council as
having capacity for abnormal or
extraordinary storm level events and
they've proposed additional conditions
to ensure surface water drainage is
dealt with in an appropriate manner
these plans show the existing tree trees
and proposed method of protection
protection which has been assessed and
generally approved by your tree officer
you're a cultural officer please note
the majority of existing trees and
hedgerows proposed to be retained and
those which are proposed to be removed
in particular alongside Hunstanton Road
are of low quality
that is viewed as acceptable now this is
a comparison plan on the right here we
have the the plan which was initially
proposed and rejected as part of the the
previous application and the the current
proposal for comparison the layout was
previously more open to the south and
east boundaries and this has been
addressed your officers consider by
increased landscape screening to these
boundaries the existing green wooden
areas
fronting Huntington Road in this
location particularly in this location
and here so the existing wouldn't
proposed to be retained any development
has been moved away from the Hunstanton
road highway frontage preserving much of
the green character area and we think
improving conditions for ecology
particularly toads which has been which
is in response to previous concerns
raised at that time to the yeast more
land has been allocated for the
attenuation Basin coming around the
corner here above the existing lake and
this is enabled to further push back of
dwellings towards the attenuation Basin
giving more room to the to the highway
frontage
under some photographs this is for the
northeast corner of the site from the
village and we have Hunstanton Road here
moving away to the south away from the
village this is a interior of the site
looking back towards that corner and the
existing wooded area group of trees to
that corner and I proposed to be
retained and they turning the camera
away looking out over the site the
existing lake here for reference and the
attenuation Basin would be adjacent in
this location here and looking at right
from that previous shot and then right
again towards the existing tree coverage
fronting Hunstanton Road and the
proposed access point would be in
approximately this location which is
also in the location of the formalized
public right-of-way route which would
connect them to almost be more
formalized in this location I mean
probably just make out the informal
roots which trodden I remember the
public this is the point of the existing
access no sorry the existing a public
right-of-way and and proposed access and
you might be able to make out the public
right-of-way sigh I'm just looking
around right
as mentioned before overgrown improved
and this is from the far southwest
corner of the site it's a location of
the right-of-way
this is the existing lake looking up
towards the existing
naturally screening to the north sir and
looking back towards the highway
frontage those access point and public
wider away in that location and then
turning away looking out to the south
away from the and south boundary of the
site and finally a view from westerly
way approaching the village from the
southeast and for reference again this
is the existing lake so the development
would be set pretty much behind that so
you have a existing screening here but
that wouldn't be improved with the
existing landscape proposal which we've
looked to secure in the reserve matters
and you'd have the proposed attenuation
Basin and approximately this location so
adding a bit of an additional landscape
feature in that way in terms of updates
there is a revised comment from the
landscape consultants at place services
and hadn't included within the table
papers and that proposed proposes
additional conditions which your
officers would ask is included should we
you be minded to approve so that include
concludes the presentation I set out
within the papers officer recommendation
of approval thank you thank you very
much questions like I've got one could
we just talk about out of the 52 at this
stage should be talking about any that
or do we have to commit to any that are
affordable yes that's part of
discussions which have already commenced
in terms of the section 106 and we'd
look to secure 35% which are 18 not
normally be at this stage that we in the
recommendation 52 of which 18 or for the
wards that just are given
[Music]
don't post t25 is it so if you've ants
the condition that just goes back over
the page so we've got the 106 to secure
the contact there 5% little difference
okay thank you
yeah cars are having him there's two
points early Alex when you say that
redefining the public footpath would be
a benefit surely they have to keep that
clear as a anyway this is a matter of
you know if you have a public footpath
across your land it's your duty surely
to keep it clearing people the brambles
away isn't that right I don't want to
comment too much on the duties and the
public right away because yeah I'm hold
him a position to make comment on that
but yeah the point is that that is that
is overgrown and the preference by
members of the public to establish their
own his eye lines through the site that
is on private land and my other point is
is there's two new sort of wildlife
ponds on the new plans who is going to
maintain and sort of take ownership of
them well that's something we would look
to negotiate and secure under the
section 106 it would be a nominated body
that could be that could be us as a
district council it could be the parish
council it could be a management company
that hasn't been secured yet but someone
will manage it cassie you been
thank you Jeff I just want to ask about
the connectivity to the village itself
there's no let's mention have not there
not being a footpath and how the public
right well she stops at the access point
and goes out of the sigh away from the
village so will there be a footpath or a
connection into the village itself of
Anderson please
we'll go back to the highway slide we
have paved footpaths here adjacent to
the metal carriageway it's also an area
roof that must be kept clear for
highways visibility displays adjacent to
that and there was a potential that will
create a potential than exists at
present that one would be able to walk
into the village and the pay footpath
network begins here that improves the
situation we would we would suggest or
is grown and offer better connections to
the start of the public right away which
at present you would have to walk down
the middle part of a carriageway which
is not ideal all safe again we would
suggest sorry could I come back on that
I'm not quite clear it is there
definitely a paved area of a path going
from the access into the site into the
village is that going to be part of this
well there would be a paved area too so
far but not all the way into the village
it would be the ability is there any
other questions yeah Council Willem
could I follow on that question at ease
there would be a paved area so far does
that mean just the yellow area who is
there and if that is the case how far is
it then from the this is on slide 10 the
footpath on that sorry the foot way that
shown in yellow on slide 10 how far is
it from there to a paved foot way into
the village and to the village village
facility
all right so the proposal is for a pay
footway at least gets people round the
corner and then you would have an area a
clear area which is required to be kept
clear by the highway authority which
visibility supplies and there would be
the ability to walk clear of the public
highway and link into the existing paved
network which begins here and that is
just adjacent to this unmade access road
to the rear of the existing dwellings in
this location and weather waste and
recycling bins are I think in this
location here so I'm not sure of the
exact distance but it's yes it's not too
far and do you want to come back well I
think I think you were talking about
using the visibility splay as as a place
to walk on which visibility spike starts
as 2.4 meters wide and take us down to
nothing there isn't any other provisions
just what I want to make sure that there
is no other provision just one other one
other query slides three four five six
and seven have a red line area on them
but I think that red line is from the
red line area of which we are at the
site which we are now considering the
comparison is actually on slide 13 I
think the red lines the red line areas
are different which is to be expected
because the site area is different but I
think I think that the earlier slides
have got the phone calling the old red
line rather than the proposal now
proposed red line am i right around
there confused
yep no problem I think what's happened
is the plotting has been taken from the
previous application so cancel while I'm
is entirely correct that the first few
slides do show the previous red line
select plan they are our plans that we
have produced not those from the
applicants and if we go to slide 13
which is page chicory 9 in the bundle we
have got on the right hand side the
previous refused application and on the
left hand side the current application
which is the red line so I plan the
applicants have submitted seus there is
a degree of variation but we are looking
at the one on the left hand side beside
their team page 239 does that help thank
that clarity okay when we understand
other questioners we move on so we don't
have any one for the parish council we
didn't have an object we didn't have a
supporter but we do have the agent for
the application Jonestown if you'd like
to come up and you have three minutes
please
good morning mr. chairman and
councillors my name is James Tanner from
Holland's architects and I'm the agent
acting on behalf of the landowner I
thank the planning officer for a clear
description and I would like to
highlight some additional key points in
support of the application the site
forms part of a form of sand and gravel
quarry which was subsequently backfilled
and therefore the land cannot be
returned to its original state pry this
use as you have heard the current
application is a resubmission of a
scheme refused in 2018 at committee
which also had officer recommendation
for approval the name of usual reasons
were settlement pattern and landscape
concerns about impact on ecology and
again some concerns over the pedestrian
highway safety it has the resubmission
we've sought to address this by a
proposed development area which retains
more of the existing tree belt
additional tree plantings in north and
eastern boundaries providing more
screening as Alex is shown the grecian
the creation of additional wildlife
ponds to provide new habitats for the
local toad population the introduction
of additional bat and bird boxes and I
think there's a bit of confusion because
we did visit a footpath along humpstor
of the section to hunt Stern Road to
connect to the main villagers footpath
network so I think there may be a bit of
confusion as a result there are no
objections from the main console tees
I'd like to come back to the ecology
because it's a key part of the revised
scheme the creation of two new wildlife
ponds means we can encourage the toad
population that hibernate in the areas
fronting constant Road to colonize the
new ponds reducing their need to cross
the road to to return to the original
breeding ponds there is an opportunity
to strengthen protect and enhance the
quality of the local colony indeed this
is reflected in the place services
ecological consultative response which
states that impact will be minimized
such that the provigil is acceptable and
goes on to say that in terms of
measurable net gain for biodiversity the
enhancements proposed will contribute to
this aim we'll have to say it's not
often I worked the scheme that in
ecological impact terms we do have a
potential for a bit of net gain we did
try to engage with a parish council but
it was clear from an early stage that
they were not supportive for the
application and I think it's in part
driven by a core group of locals who
unofficially roamed the privately owned
land with pets far from the divine
footpaths and do not wish this to change
I would also point out that there is a
balance of some 32 letters in support of
the application I would like also to
point out the decide is relatively
straightforward with no complex access
or ownership issues that would affect
deliverability the applicant is
committed to bringing the site forward
and there is recorded interest expressed
from a developer who would be keen to
comment works on site as soon as is
practical so in accordance with revised
mpps commitment to identifying sites
which are deliverable and given the
local planning authorities current
housing supply position the proposal
represents in my mind an excellent
opportunity to make a significant and
positive contribution to the district's
housing targets thank you three minutes
do we have any questions at this point
councillor Willem then Cassie thank you
chip could you clarify what you said
about the footpath connection now you
said it very quickly I understand sorry
could you could you clarify that with
the aid of perhaps a slide yeah I think
it's if you could bring up the main not
that one that the actual sort of sites
yeah but that one yeah we had envisioned
from the access that there would be a
section of a footpath to link back
towards me across the front there it
sort of shown on on this drawing if you
blow it up a bit but it perhaps it
wasn't put in the other engineer drawing
cuz that concentrated more on the access
so I think we had envisaged that there
would be a more formalized section of
footpath to connect to the village
services but maybe that's something that
we would still need to go back and and
just clarify with with the highway
thought maybe it's just a lost and I
just clarify so from your access to the
end of the red line on there where
there's a yeah a track back that way you
would use talked about there yeah you
would construct a paved foot way and
that's what we had in mind yeah
we could if we wanted to when we get to
the condition that thank you yeah
calorie burn Thank You chair but my
question was about the pot as well so
thanks okay any other questions nope
thank you very much thank you very much
you good time
so we now move on to the ward member
house man over to you thank you Miss Jim
I'm here as all remember but the parish
council have asked me to speak on their
behalf and they asked me to emphasize
them two of their objections firstly the
development is considered too large for
the village and secondly the existing
village does not have the infrastructure
to cope with the additional 52 houses I
was very interested to hear the the
officer quote quite a few services the
village has a shop a pub and three buses
to Barry and this in one day but that's
the sum total pretty much all the
services it's true that's in the core
strategy the village is listed as a
primary village a primary village if I
might quote that is has basic local
services including a primary school and
a shop the village does not have a
primary school so if it's not a primary
village then it must be a secondary
village which would benefit from
small-scale development if you look at
the draft local plan bad wash is listed
as a hinterland village one of 43 such
villages those villages over the next 18
years have to deliver 1174 houses that
breaks down to approximately 28 per
village or 2.3 percent bad Welsh
currently has planning permission for
120 houses or just shy of 120 houses so
are already carrying 10 percent of the
total deliverable houses for hinterland
villages if this application is approved
that percentage will rise to 13 percent
for a village that lacks many of the
services required of a primary village I
believe that is too heavy and that
supports the parish councils position
I'd also like to point out
sustainability the officer considers the
site to be sustainable location it has
no school it has no doctor surgery it
has extremely limited recreational
facilities I don't believe it is
sustainable and if you look again at the
poor strategy sustainability is defined
to provide a sustainable development and
respond to the implication of climate
change by reducing midst of its carbon
footprint every child on every day of
their academic career will be bused to
various schools the vast majority of
journeys to dr. surges will be by car
three buses to bury doesn't give you
very much scope and hence the private
car will be a major contributor and
hence I don't believe this is
sustainable the village has and is not
against development it is already
carrying more than its fair share this
development pushes that even higher and
I think we should accept these houses
would add to that carbon footprint
bad well ash is a small village with
very limited facilities this development
I believe is too large and hence I
support the parish councils position I
don't you to reject the application
thank you thank you for that I've just
got a quick question can we just have
clarity about its status as a primer of
secondary village set out as a primary
village I accept all the counselor is
saying about the services there but
there are specifically listed by village
rather than by the services they may or
may not have so the assessment would be
the basis of proper this the primary
village can we just any other questions
at all yeah council having Hamlin
Councilwoman just a quick the buses
every day do you say three buses a day
there's three buses to bury I believe in
three to dis every day Thank You chair
um you heard what the applicant said all
the architects said about providing the
footpath would that footpath then link
to the place where children would get on
a bus and if so well in any case which
schools are they bussed to I would
imagine that the senior school is
Thurston Community College the nearest
schools to the village are washing
willows which is I believe currently
oversubscribed Norton and then with a
major new primary school being developed
in Staunton around the old middle school
site the buses would go to those three
because normally the bus and he goes but
normally only goes to one I wondered if
you knew which is why that one tell you
to a nearest school
yep wrong with the nearest school is
they may not get it
hence they'll be allocated schools
elsewhere any other questions thank you
very much so members we've had all the
information put before us we've heard
from the author from the officers
presentation we've heard from the
applicant or the agent and we've heard
from the ward member services now to
discuss debate and come to a conclusion
but they were you know always happy to
run fill up our quota houses this one is
it's got me a bit worried and for
starters the whole you know buses to
school I mean we all know if we've got
children either primary or you know
secondary school how long are these
three buses going to last and it says um
and on Sam Harvey's report on page two
four three that you know um that you
know I mean like I say although she
doesn't object she doesn't seem to be
very happy about it saying that the
catchment school is you know three point
eight miles away and that secondary
school is six miles away the bus stop is
300 meters in the center of the site and
there's no visitor pop visitor car
parking which I don't think is a good
frankly and well and there's several
things she says that don't have
sufficient sight lines to maneuver
safely different sort of sufficient
visibility on several plots
anyway I'm you know I'm worried about
this thing that's what I'm saying all
those matters of reserve matters
yeah so we just need to be careful what
we're deciding on today yeah thank you
can I seek some clarification from the
offices over the where we are with the
five-year land supply because are we to
give absolutely no weight to the
information that we have in terms of the
draft figure of five point three two
because I'm trying to I'm trying to see
whether or not
mind we're in the same position with
this application as we were when we sat
at the inquiry at the for the war pit
application because I I feel that in my
in my head I've got more confidence over
the 5.32 here than I had over the figure
that was being quoted at warp it am I
wrong to take that into account so the
current land supplied number is out for
consultation so it could go up or down
so I wouldn't give a significant amount
of weight that land supply figure one
way or the other at the moment what I
would say is following the wallpaper
decision and various others that we've
had is they have declared a lot of our
policies out of date because of their
level of compliance or otherwise in fact
we clean up state MPPs so the amendments
last year in this year's the MPP F one
of the main policies we've got left it
does comply with the MPP F is F C 1.1
which talks about sustainable
development so ultimately regardless of
land supply the boat we're in is looking
at is this sustainable development not
specifically we've got a landslide it's
outside the redline we should say no we
should say we need to look at it in the
round in terms of sustainability looking
at both the MPP F and then F C 1.1 cus
nice thank you I have considerable
reservations about this application
we've heard from the board member that
bed wash does not have a great deal of
facilities the comments on post 241 from
the parish council or a number of points
there that give me concern planning
applications outside the village
boundary the excesses of great concern
being on a bend at the brow the hill
creating a blind spot for existing
traffic and towards their list of their
comments the councillors noted to Fire
and Rescue Services comments not
regarding not enough water pressure on
the site
now find me the counselors no to the NHS
comments that they do not have the
capacity to deal with the extra homes
all these sort of negative factors to
this application do give me considerable
concern I won't be able to support this
in its present form thank you
I just think I need to remind members
that you're going to have to give lots
of planning reasons as to why we if you
don't like it why it's being refused we
can't just say because yes other reasons
you've given our planning reasons so we
need to be very specific we did if
that's the route you want to go down we
have to have planning reasons for
refusal but we'll keep going and see
where it takes us counselor yep who is
next
Thank You chair um I don't have so many
concerns about this because I think that
the you know it is absolutely right on
the edge of the village boundary and if
their foot Way is going to be going from
the side into the into the village you
know and there are you know I mean for a
village in which suffered to me there's
a reasonable services having out having
a shop and having very regular buses
into into town and buses that take you
know children to school I mean that's
quite a common factor of most villages
in the district so what I've got I've
got less of an issue really and I think
you know this is that and this is an
outline outline we're looking at now so
I think a lot of those things also the
comments that we made you know by the
parish council and so on can probably be
addressed and I would hope that the
developers would actually engage fully
with the parish council in order to make
sure all of their concerns are met but
at the moment I don't you know I it
seems to be a kind of reasonable
development right on the edge of the
village and provided the connectivity is
there you know I'm and their meat
particularly all the ecological concerns
that been raised with the previous
occasion I wait to see what others say
thank you thank you very much Chancellor
yep different customer Thank You chair
yes I do have some concerns about this
development the particularly access into
the village and we really would need to
tie this down the previous plan which is
shown on slide 13 actually shows a very
fair pathway looping through the site
onto the edge of the existing village
which would be a to my mind a much
better footpath than something on the
roadside
I do also note the concerns of people
about the sight lines of the access
although the Suffolk County Council
don't seem to have picked up on that
particularly but it is on the slight
brow as you go over down towards the
stream there and that does present to me
a little bit of a concern about sight
lines the Boche did have a school until
I think five or six years ago maybe
that's the reason why it was originally
put put in as a primary village but that
school closed and now people are bused
elsewhere and I believe actually that
the nearest secondary school to this
site would be extra three school so
given that the Suffolk County counselors
chain is changing things that there may
not be free School Bus provision from
here to first and in the near future so
I have some serious concerns about it
it's on the edge of the village it
doesn't seem to be we don't have an
absolutely kind of set in stone pathway
for people to walk or cycle into the
village and it would tend to lend itself
to people using the car more more and
more thank you thank you very much
anyone else
well I mean I kind of feel from where I
sit my view is that it came to committee
back in November 2018 and the committee
sent it away with three key points under
on pages 2 & 9 & 2:10 and actually the
three points were about the the way the
settlement patent and as a character of
the site and they've moved everything
back from the road which is what they
were asked to do and they were asked to
take into account those points they were
then asked to look at the ecology and
biodiversity and obviously they've now
talked about bringing in these two ponds
and pedestrian safety
so they've brought a they're talking
about building a footpath and if they
don't I think would have whichever
direction we head if you know if it goes
towards one way towards bru we can
always put in as a condition but they
were asked to look at pedestrian safety
and it seems that that has also been
picked up on so the reasons for refusal
last time have been addressed but on the
other hand we've heard from the ward
member who still has concerns as did the
Parish Council so sitting on the outside
just on the edge of the village to me
that isn't you know that's that's what
we see a lot of applications like that
they have to go round what is the core
long as there's access to the center of
town which the footpath hopefully would
give absolutely the car is always and is
always a concern I mean you know three
buses is three more than I think the
majority of my residents have at all and
where I have no buses in the majority of
my patch ever so it to me that's
actually you know that's a good
transport think but yeah so I'm really
torn on this one as to which way to go
the applicant has come back and made
some real considerations at the points
that were raised last time so I'm
probably steering more towards
supporting it than not but I'm stop the
discussion debate
anyone else Castle well then Charlie I'm
pretty much where you I think with this
one the devil is in the detail because
it is a fairly open sight as you look at
it from one particular direction and I
think if there is a high quality layer
for the housing and high quality
landscaping then this is a site that
could be developed we do need that we do
need make sure by condition that there
is a foot way linked to the end of the
existing foot way my only concern about
that is that if there is a piece of land
in between that the applicant does not
contain we might end up with a couple of
bits of walkway so is there any way that
we can we can be sure that that it is
possible to link it perhaps perhaps the
applicant knows the answer to that
we're just having a look at the redline
site BAM but they do look to own the
land up to the edge of the highway so we
could get the footpath to go through the
sites all the way to the north of the
site and then join onto the highway so I
don't think we would be in a position
where you would get to the edge of the
site and find you're approaching a wall
or a fence for example it looked to me
like we could secure footpath through to
the edge of the site albeit little
probably beyond a control what happens
outside of the redline but certainly in
that red line up to the highway it looks
to me like we could secure it but Alex
is that fatty oh yes that's certainly my
impression to confirm that perhaps we
could ask the applicants agent again
just to confirm
I'm so is there a footpath right from
where the applicant sounds but is that
the rest of the foot part of the village
there was a footpath there is there just
across the way if we go to the slide
number nine so we're talking about
having the footpath running along there
then you can see you come to an access
track as it's being called so there is a
gap between the red line and the access
track what so are we saying that would
be that's the issue I guess
show me the issue how you yeah so on the
other side of that track is there than a
pavement all the way into the village
yes all right serious okay thank you
Casa Mila Thank You chair well haven't
listened to all the comments etc and
despite the earlier application being
refused I think you know efforts have
been made to address those issues so I
am mindful to go for approval on this
and we'll be happy to propose approval
thank you with a condition on the
footpath running all the way through to
the track so that access so there is a
clear line clear access to the to the
village okay anyone else you burn in an
earthen I think you're looking for
second origin I'm having it haven't
heard all the comments and don't think
you know I think given particularly as
if a committee you know rejects a
refuses an application on particular
grounds and then the applicant does come
back and address that's all of those
then I hear the parish councils comments
but we would hope that they would meet
you know I hope the applicant will meet
with the parish council to actually
address the comments within the site for
the one reserved matters come forward
and so I'll be happy to second it
provided there is the foot off going to
through to the to the village else wish
to speak councillor one can I just ask
for clarification on the condition which
reads timetable for implementation and
retention of landscaping and compare
that with with what the officer is put
in seven point eight which is a
comprehensive landscaping strategy I
would I would wonder whether it would be
better to have comprehensive landscaping
strategy as a condition rather than just
the retention of landscaping
well that comprehensive strategy we
would expect as part of reserve matters
as landscaping but if we wanted that
highlighted
yeah okay so it's been proposed by
cancer Miller seconded by cancer Eve
burn as per the recommendation laid out
from the papers on two to five and two
to six with the inclusion of a a line
along the lines of a footpath to be
provided from the site to meet the
existing access to the village all those
in favor of the recommendation can never
shake hands please
five days against and abstentions okay
thank you very much we'll take a quick
10 minute break start again at 20 to 12
for the next item on the agenda
so a move straight on to item 70 on the
agenda which is a DC 1901 793 and
Bradley a would you to present the
application thank you sorry counsel well
I'm I'm grace or I started I thought I
was the one that was lost in so sorry
you haven't missed something you've only
read out the name the number of the
application okay thank you chair good
morning members
ladies and gentlemen this application
before you being asked to consider a
reserved matters proposal for a new
warehouse on land at black acre Hill
Bamford Road great Blakeman the yellow
line you can see or the yellow arrow
there give you an approximate location
of the site and also usefully shows
great Blakeman and clayton and also the
a14 drunk road this hatched area you can
see one plan is that the area to which
on planning permission has been granted
for B 1 + B 8 use or principally B 1 B 8
use in effect the whole of that area
shown hatched has outlined planning
permission for commercial industrial
uses the area of the site that you're
being asked to consider the overall site
you've been asked to consider today is
aged red here and you see it's got an
access leading up to the point of access
on the main road and the other areas of
that are under the ownership will
control of the applicant or shown it
blue the constraints map there's limited
constraints that would be impacted or
the affect the consideration the
application you've got a cluster of
listed buildings in this location to the
south and you've got a TPO as you can
say as you can see the way to the north
and special landscape designation which
is
on the other side of the main road
unfortunate doesn't come out very very
green but it follows that roughly that
line there so the SLA is on the other
side of the road this plan shows the
hatched area are referred to previously
is the overall development site and this
is the extent of flood zones 2 & 3 so as
you can see it's outside of flood zones
and lastly that plan shows potentially
contaminated land and the area is shown
as being outside of that this is an
aerial map which will give you an idea
of land uses in the location as you can
see to the north-northeast is generally
commercial development and the wider
area is mainly rural dispersed dispersed
with sort of houses dispersed within
that this is a site locate sorry this is
the plan of the proposed development
excuse me what you're being asked to
look at is this building here which is
essentially a large box which is going
to be is proposed to use the p8 storage
and distribution use and a smaller
element here which is B 1 which is the
administration element of the building
this area here is the lorry park where
people will come in lorries are come in
and deliver and collect goods and this
area on the corner is staff parking the
other thing I don't think it's worth
pointing out at this point is the
landscaping proposal on the corner
bearing in mind that this reserved
matters application and landscaping is
one of the one of the elements that
you're being asked to consider the green
area I should point out that the north
point on this plan is actually that way
confusingly so the year the group the
blue area to the south of the site shows
and attenuation Basin but you're not
being asked to consider the
appropriateness of that because surface
water drainage was considered as part of
the outline planning application and a
series of conditions were attached the
outline planning permission which are in
the process of being considered at this
point in time this is the design of the
proposed building as you can say as a
describe recently is fundamentally a
large box of a large single volume unit
it has been broken down by dint of the
the use of pile grooves here to suggest
incremental volumes the other approach
to try and break down the overall mass
is the use of different colored material
two different shades of gray metallic
material in a banding which which helps
to deal with the overall volume and that
element in the corner there you can just
see is the office administration one and
the gates four sorry the access points
for the lorries this is the floor plan
fairly simple as you'd expect a lot of
area given over to storage rack storage
and you can see in the left hand bottom
part the and that is a floor plan of
that various fused to finish off with
this is the land at present
note the existing industrial development
in the vicinity including the waste
treatment plant here again you can see
an edge of the white treatment waste
treatment plant and also this will give
you some order this this drawing sorry
this photograph and this photograph and
the following one of the sort of
topography it is a sloping site slopes
down towards the south so any
development on this site will have some
sort of prominence
in the overall landscape and that
feature there is an existing band of
aging and trees which is on the southern
end of the site which would assist in
the screaming provision and I've
included that as a as an example of a
building nearby which again as you can
see is form follows function is a
simplistic commercial structure I'd like
to think that what you're being asked to
consider today is probably pushing the
envelope a bit further that making a bit
more of an effort in terms of visual
impact bearing in mind the functional
nature of the structure I'll leave that
slide up as I finished my presentation
we're again I think it's useful in terms
of context briefly this is the existing
commercial development to the north and
to the north east the site we're talking
about sits approximately in that
location here and the nearest dwellings
are in this location which some of which
it has been identified in my report are
listed so overall we think that this is
an acceptable planning response as a
reserved matters application for an
industrial building on what is an agreed
industrial site thank you thank you very
much any questions yeah the Bloods
authority holding objection been sorted
oh yes
referring back to what I said about
discharge of conditions of what happened
in this particular case we had a
discharge condition application and this
reserved matters application
consultation responses went out to both
sets of quantities on both but the
distinction wasn't understood between
the two I don't think by the console
tease in their response
so the
issues in relation to drainage and
surface water are actually being
addressed under the discharge of
condition application and they're not
relevant to the consideration of this
but as it's a background paper you
should be can considered or you know
included in your in your bundle Casa
Willem Thank You chair I've got a few
questions
you showed us slide 18 you showed us a
building with a flat roof how does the
height of that building compare with the
height of the proposed building please
you must write 18
in truth I haven't measured the height
of that I would dare say because of the
overall volume and Eve sigh and the use
of that building odd there so that was
equivalent in height by in truth I can't
tell you exactly what the difference is
that's the African can we can probably
ask the app yeah okay that's fine
the the banding which adds a bit of
interest I've seen lots of buildings
with banding usually the darkest is at
the bottom with the lightest ISM is at
the top so that it tends to sort of go
into the sky bit this is the other way
around that seems rather odd was there
was there pre-op discussion about about
that if the applicants nodding with his
finger up so I think there's another
question for him there if you haven't
got anything you want I guess the next
question is also just just in case
anything you want to I haven't got any
particular comment about that if it's
gonna be addressed by the application
the other question was going to be is
there a need for visitors carpark we've
talked about lorry parking and staff
parking are there likely to be visitors
in vans or cars or whatever the standard
that supplied is a maximum standard as
I've said in the report that takes into
account staff and I think that there's
spaces for disabled motorists and
cyclists as well I suspect again by dint
of use that all the spaces wouldn't be
occupied at the same time so therefore
there is an inference that there were
there isn't actually a visitor standard
in relation to B 1 and B a as far as I'm
aware I think that's encompassed within
the whole standard but I think we're
happy with the amount that's being
promoted promoted under this scheme any
other questions
No oh yeah every class even I'm thinking
[ __ ] can I just ask white lighting as is
what lighting is proposed of this side
there are no proposals for lighting
under this under this submission because
it's a reserved matters for the building
but it's an important point because as
part of the conditions are imposed on
the the outline there wasn't there was
one specifically in relation to lighting
for each phase of the development so
that would be controlled under that as
well thank you much okay so we have a
new one from the Parish Council and
objects are no supporter but we do have
the agent and the applicant mr. Nick
Davie and Larry issue would if you'd
like to come up I think you already know
some of the questions but first of all
if we could go into three minutes piece
and we will and you could keep the three
minutes and we can take questions after
[Music]
maybe factory much if it's ok I'll deal
with those issues drew questions I was
on listened to my three minutes yeah so
I have miss research with me here he's
from the develop of the applicant so he
can also answer any questions at the end
that you may have so yes this is the
first of the warehouse of just six
buildings that he's being brought
forward under the outlined plan of
mission which the council has granted
under that permission and conditions
which we've been working our way through
and discharging we've dealt with ecology
archaeology transport landscape access
visual impact trees and neighbors etc
and this design the design of this
building is based upon the details which
were in the design and access statement
and the drawings answer council saw as
part of that outline application so the
heights are all set at that our line
application stage of the building it's
also achieved all the council's
requirements are set out in the
conditions for sustainability and
breanne and it will generate portion of
its their own energy via photovoltaic
cells on the roof
groundworks also been designed so that
no earth needs to be taken off-site
we're taking advantage of the sloped or
imported onto site the concrete in the
aggregate for the floor slabs they will
all be sourced locally from within two
miles the internal lighting scheme
that's lower will be low-energy
rainwater will be harvested to irrigate
the landscape proposals and under the
section 106 agreement a dedicated bus
service is going to be provided between
the site great Blake and them and it's
which for the life of the development
and that's all secured under the 106
agreement which is part of the outlined
consent so that's confirmed by your
planning officer the proposal is fully
compliant with the principles
established at the outline stage and I
would like to emphasize that this is not
a speculative scheme we have a tenant
lined up heads of terms agreed to take a
25-year lease of the building they are
the FDS group who are currently based on
the ransoms Business Park and they're
looking to greatly expand their UK
operations and they need a much larger
building and this is where they want to
come so they can do all their operations
from this site rather than shipping in
stuff from abroad it represents a
sixteen and a half million pound
investment for my client as well as a
multi-million pound investment for fds
and when completed we're told that it
will initially employ 60 to 80 full-time
staff working three shifts and that's
expected to rise to 120 250 within two
years as your planning officer said
there is one out outstanding outline
application so other application dealing
with all the other conditions precedent
and surface water drainage and the
Venice lagoon is all part of that
application and there are ongoing
discussions which are information with
the llfe and the county so we hope that
members can our endorsee officer
recommendation and approve the consent
if you can what we'll start in early
September on this scheme and it's due
for completion by June 2020 my client
also has a number of other tenants lined
up for three other buildings
they're just waiting for work to
commence and then they're going to
commit to leases as well and I've
sprayed the three minutes is I say if
you just have the last sentence version
finally I'm so just one final thing I've
been asked to say it is very important
that consent be granted today we need to
deliver this to FDS by June 2020 if we
can't get on site by September that puts
Adams yet for at jeopardy in both SDS
and the funding may may walk away thank
you very much I'll leave counsel well um
do you want to go first with your
question thank you I would like to add
one other question if I may
the first the first question was will
there be visitors other than just staff
and lorries is it totally a lorries in
lorries out or is it lorries in do some
work cars come and collect stuff that
you're you're selling and the other
question two other questions one was the
height is it a similar height to the
building that we saw on the slide and
why is the banding to other way around
from I really expected yes
Laura's in Laura's out all goods move in
and out by lorries no one will come and
collect clients will come and click from
the side so the carpark is purely for
staff and the old visitor who may come
to discuss a contract or something of
that nature and then you also have to
dedicate your bus service I've described
earlier which has to be in place before
any unit on the on the site is occupied
and as to Heights it is larger than the
building you saw on that site it's sort
of more equivalent to the incinerator
unit next door but that was all
discussed at the outline stage and the
key thing there and this also goes to
the banding was views from Clayton on
the other side the valley we were asked
to make sure that the building was below
the line of the trees which along are
along the southern and the western
boundaries
the site if you go to the if you could
see the aerial photograph for that
reason that's also the reason why the
banding what's the other way normally
you're quite right
the lighter banding will be at the top
so the top of the building disappears a
bit into the sky here if the top of the
building isn't going to be seen against
the sky it's going to be seen against
the the trees along the western and the
southern boundaries and it was felt
right from the initial stage the best
way to deal with the mass of the
building which I actually have the
banding working the other way so that's
the reason it goes up to top rather
license as it goes up don't say you
don't learn something new every time we
do this committee any other questions
if these 18 meters to to the top yep any
other questions from colleagues it's
also dug in so it's a lot of custom
filter which is what we don't have to
import or take her the earth off-site
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you for your time the board member is
counselor field who has since an email
because he can't be here today so I'll
read this out my views on the
application are as follows the land at
black acre Hill Branford Road great
Blake in him is an appropriate location
for the form of logistics related
development proposed in this application
situation close to the a14 plate
injunction the economic benefit to the
area will be welcomed the site is
connected to the clade injunction by one
kilometer approximately of dual
carriageway a traffic light controlled
right turn to a few hundred meters
single carriageway and a left turn
entrance vehicles entering or leaving
the site have no need to pass
residential properties traffic through
these junctions is at peak hours
approach and capacity with queues
building to some tens of vehicles so
transport plan that schedule HDTV of
arrivals and departures to avoid such
times would be advantageous better to
other users of the route and the
operators of the facility the committee
should note that this is a route used by
vehicles accessing the
a state in need a market vacations
isolated by traffic restrictions of
needed market such as wash from airfield
Clayton Business Park from dwellings
include the new 417 and 130 home
developments in Blakeman fields and
Blake in a mill I'm concerned the office
of recommendation accepts a building
that has identified as 48 meters high
some 10 meters higher than the adjacent
incinerator on the basis that the new
building is a similar industrial form to
its award-winning neighbor my concern is
more about the accuracy of the
assessment as a brief examination of the
drawings reveals the height is an a OD
figure and ground level is 30 meters a
OD giving a building weight height of 18
meters however I'd like that confirmed
if the reports figure is correct then
the building's will dominate residential
properties nearby
my final comment would be around the
drainage arrangements the Parish Council
correctly points to the flooding issues
of the Bron third road and the county
appears to be still of the view that
drainage proposals are not satisfactory
officers point out these matters should
be agreed as part of outline of the
outline application however if
permission is giving to proceed with the
development without agreement there is a
strong presumption that nothing will
change
councillor john field
to start off if no one else really wants
to I mean I look I think this is a great
opportunity for mid Suffolk to bring a
business in that's in a location next to
the energy for waste which is something
that's dear to all our hearts as it's
multi-award-winning and to hear that
actually they're going for Brienne
status the concrete is coming or the the
base of the units coming locally clearly
the environmental impact has been
considered the color-coding shows the
thought and consideration that's gone in
to try and mitigate the local concerns
the PV panels that have been talked
about the flooding issues we've covered
and I believe that has been addressed
but I'll just like confirmation when the
officers at the point that drawn field
makes that that is addressed as well and
quite frankly you know we want to
encourage growth in mid Suffolk and to
have a company of this size wanting to
move and base itself in mid Suffolk in
what I deemed to be a totally
appropriate location for that I think is
what true is very much welcome and
clearly great works gone on between the
applicant and mid suffer to try and
engineer something that fits him as well
as it can so from my perspective I
welcome it could you just touch on the
flooding issue that John field mentioned
please thank you yes as part of the
airline application as I said there was
a serious conditions in relation to
surface water drainage both on site and
obviously in relation to the access
which has been dealt with under separate
applications the highway Authority would
consider the elements of the site or the
suitability of the scheme put forward in
order that a flooding issue wasn't
created in relation to local highway
network so we're happy that both of the
elements both on site and access and I
think that you know they cover the
concerns that were raised by the parish
council in that regard you can give us
total confidence the issues on the
flooding that have been raised by John
field are covered
we'll be covered under the conditions
that's that's correct yes thank you
casa milà sure I must have it I think
the economic benefits of this as you
quite rightly point out share it's going
to increase the number of employees it's
a large firm moving to this area we want
to encourage these type of companies to
come here it is an ideal site for this I
fully support this application and
therefore move approval
thank you thank you very much yeah cat
sonorous psycho yes I would like to
support the recommendation no there have
been some mentions of drainage issues by
the parish council but I think they have
already been covered in the outlined
application I know the area quite well
and I think it will bring a lot of
economic benefit to the area so I would
be happy to support this recommendation
seconding yes yeah okay anyone else wish
to speak yeah council having him I'm
trying to say that putting also putting
on a bus tips which i think is that you
know going above and beyond the call of
duty which i think it's excellent okay
so it's been proposed by councilor
mother seconded by councillor Norris as
per the recommendations laid out in our
papers on pages three one three of our
papers all those in favor of the
recommendation if you have a show of
hands please that's unanimous thank you
very much
okay the final item for today is on page
three five three of our papers
application number DC 1900 174
and Vince you're taking this on behalf
of Catherine thank you
[Music]
thank you Jeff we're looking at a
variation of conditions three on the
site here at William meadow Church Road
Bettis foot site sits on the sits on the
bend in here what we have is a condition
an application permission that restricts
the use of four new holiday let's to a
period that excludes eights of January
to the 8th of February so there's one
month in the year but they cannot be
occupied and it is restricted to holiday
let's the applicant is seeking to have
that condition lifted in order that
there can be all year-round occupation
effectively residential use rather than
holiday let's the condition was
originally added it'll see from the
bottom of the screen as highlighted in
yellow the site of the permission is
outside of any area where planning
permission would normally be forthcoming
for residential development
the whole of that area is within a
triple si here we have the aerial view
you'll notice the pear drop shape which
is pointing out the site Bettis photo
sits to the northwest of hips which on
the way very some edmonds so here we
have what was approved in May 2017 so
you'll see that there are four cabins
there is one two three four these three
overlooker a pond so there are four
other day let's in the form of log cabin
there is one of the log cabins there's
another one that sits behind it you can
just see the corner it poking out in the
background so what you're being asked to
consider is not the lifting of the
condition in respect of all four you're
looking at changing the condition to
allow the two log cabins shown in red to
be used for residential use the two log
cabins shown blue would continue to be
available as holiday let's with that
restriction
in terms of what is on the site of
present the two yellow rectangles
represent hard standings concrete hard
standings when the case officer went out
that is what exists at the moment the
two rectangles colored green are
actually the log cabins that have been
erected and they were in that photograph
that we just looked at the actual
lifting of the condition relates to one
existing log cabin and what currently
what is a hard standing there's a shot
of the two existing log cabins across
the the pond this is from the applicants
website
zooming in they open out with the
sliding doors to have a view of the pond
again from the applicants website here
you'll notice it's suggesting you can
buy one of the cabins on a 99 year lease
for 150 150 yep 150 thousand also on the
website this is just a promotional video
there is no sound
that's the presentation I'm happy to
take questions as when they arise - I'm
prefer a tongue I don't understand so so
planning application was only given back
18 months ago is that correct
sorry in - in May 2017 correct to build
for holiday homes of which only two have
been built and an applications come in -
to convert one that isn't even built to
be sold off as an individual property
that is correct although I can't
necessarily say it is being sold off in
theory but what's being applied it's a
free-standing house that could be sold
off as a separate I know we're seeing a
99-year lease but if but what was the
factories being asked for this for
something that isn't even build and
hasn't been occupied and hasn't actually
run as a business to be sold off as a
separate dwelling is what's being asked
effectively yes okay and and it's within
an area where you cannot build houses
like this if you say wished ordinarily
you would not expect to approve new
dwellings in the open countryside hence
the reason for the shown on that
condition originally it was restricted
to equality let's because that's how it
was promoted and that was identified as
the need any other questions that
council Willam chair thank you um other
parking standards for residential homes
different from parking standards for
holiday let's do tow garage and bin
collation and there probably are other
things as well whenever you ask about
those three in terms of parking
standards as it sits within the farm
there is more than enough space for
anyone to park in terms of the refuse
collection I'm not sure what the
arrangements
ah it could be that the applicant has a
commercial arrangement to have waste
rubbish from the unit's collected not
follow the counsel system I just don't I
don't know I also don't know how how
well used the two existing units are and
how much rubbish they they generate so
that's not a entirely adequate answer
but that is the answer I have to give
you at this stage I am sorry I haven't
finished my questions in that's right
I'm John the key said can i but i'm i
just need clarity on this so when
someone comes forward with a holiday
units
normally this would have build a
business case and you know you'd say
this is what i want to do it because you
believe there's demand in the area for
holiday accommodation so can you go from
not actually having delivered that so
the business case hasn't been stepped up
because thousand or be built it's not
all up and running to suddenly stop that
halfway through I mean is there no
condition that actually the first
approval has to actually be up and right
it's like a pub you know we have pubs
come here that want to convert to a
house and they have to have a business
plan to show that they've tried to make
a go of it to then convert it into
something else is there no nothing on on
this approach you may feel there's a
deficiency in policies but you're quite
right for dinner early if you expected
somebody to want a house in the
countryside let's say for an essential
agricultural worker you would expect
them to present a business case and for
that restriction to be applied in
perpetuity because the only reason you
will have allowed it is because it is
required for an essential agricultural
worker when it comes to holiday that we
do not have a policy with that same
rigor so somebody promotes a proposal as
being good for tourism you don't be
familiar with the fact that the council
the district advertises its tourism
attraction as having great access to the
countryside they sees in the countryside
it is remote from settlements
therefore you would expect there to be a
demand for a a cabin adjacent to a pond
in the open countryside what we haven't
got is is evidence to indicate why that
hasn't succeeded how well it was
marketed you saw a an extract but that
isn't necessarily on the you have to
have search hard to find it
it I think it is a policy issue because
you're quite rough that does seem to be
a tension between attracting tourism in
the form of holiday lights and resisting
residential development in the open
countryside
um no physical works are proposed as the
unit's vehicle access and parking exist
they don't exist that they don't exist
physically yet but they exist as
permitted something that's permitted
under the permission is that's the point
isn't it but I come back to the proposal
in front of us no physical works are
required well I would say chairman is
that we haven't been out in in recent
weeks whether or not other cabins have
emerged specially something you might
want to ask Li says no physical works
are proposed as it all exists as its
existing but it's not existing as the
photo shown when was the last site visit
done by an officer on this I believe
that was in
okay well we can ask the applicant I
suppose we could do a site visit and any
any other questions at this point right
okay
so we'll move on so thank you for that
we don't have the Parish Council now the
parish council can't be here and they
have submitted something in our late
papers so I'm not gonna read it out
because I wouldn't normally do that but
because they can't be here they have
submitted in the lake papers on page 17
so as long as members have seen that and
that just came in on the 22nd of July so
we have that's from the Parish Council
we have no objector no supporter but we
do have the applicant at Georgina NOC
and Kristen if you'd like to come up for
your three minutes please
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
councillors I'm Georgina NOC and this is
my father Chris not pure help with the
questions today in 2016 our family
farming business realized that we needed
a new source of income for the business
to survive and bring in the next
generation which is myself and my
brother James and there was an existing
leisure enterprise at Williams meadow
with the two fishing lakes which he
rented out with giving angular Club we
consulted with the anglers about placing
the lodges next to the lakes and they
happily agreed and we're thankful that
we approached them in the first place we
obtained planning permission for the
four lodges at one miss meadow on the
farm in May 2017 the first two largest
was delivered in August 2017 from local
Suffolk based manufactures up in Brandon
during 2018 we sold one Lodge for
recreational use and rented out the
other one which is on sites from the
start from Summer 2018 up to summer 2019
however during 2018 we were Priestley
asked by numerous inquiries if they
could live this it's been been carefully
landscaping the place and creating a
beautiful place we've also won awards
for our sustainability practices
especially regarding renewable energy
on-site we applied for pre-emptive ice
on whether we could alter the condition
3 on the permission to change
recreational to designation residential
for two of the four plots based on the
positive pre apps a response we then
submitting the application so we can
still run a leisure of recreational
business alongside to residential lodges
on-site we also asked if we could have
12 months use of the recreational lodges
rather than the present 11 months the
pre apt advice was given on 12 of
December 2018 and this concluded a quote
is unlikely that the council would
oppose the reconstruction of Christian
dition 3 on the plan commission and the
conversion of the recreational use some
of the lodges were not unacceptable
given the weights of the Inspectorate
decision sitting behind them also in pre
apt advice was a request that the
council would want to be assured
regarding the level of residential
amenity offered to the potential
permanent
it's of the lodges with this advice
wheeler submitted application on the
11th of January 2019 given the two plots
of residential use more private amenity
and the landscape has matured
beautifully to fit in with the natural
character of the area the rules also
locates allocated more parking spaces
and storage space closer to plots this
curious young site will also benefit
from having people there all year round
regarding the point raised from the
parish council they did not follow
protocol and allow for my father to have
the three minutes where he would have
been able to explain the positive pre-op
device from the council therefore an
uninformed decision was made for these
reasons above I would like to ask the
committee if the plot 1 & 4 can be
changed to residential designation and
put plot to you free to be changed to a
12-month recreational designation the
Chairman's point regarding the lodge not
on site yet it allows person to bespoke
the design of the lodge and that's what
we feel very important to do so thank
you very much for your time thank you
very much and you just went over three
minutes I'll let you because you were
answering a question dad councillor had
questions did you say that you'd already
sold one of the lodges we did but that
fell through just a couple of months ago
so it didn't reach completion
unfortunately
and I have got a copy here of the pre-op
advice and the pre-op advice was it is
unlikely that accounts would be
receptive to a complete removal of the
restrictive condition on the use of
holiday lets and from the discussion
held at the meeting Intel's unlikely
that while summer lodgers were being
considered for conversion to residential
use two others could remain as holiday
units and that's in that's a record our
record of the meeting that was and that
letter was sent to you on the 12th of
December 2018 condition this is unlikely
that the council would be receptive to a
complete removal of the restrictive
condition on the use of the holiday
let's and from the discussion held at
the meeting it is likely that while some
of the lodgers were being considered for
conversion to a residential use two
others would remain as holiday less the
condition clearly thence it still serves
a purpose with regards to the units
remaining as holiday lights as it's
considered reason what this use would
still be restricted no so that doesn't
bind the committee in any way but it's
just the minutes and a letter that was
sent from that meeting so that
everyone's clear what was discussed any
questions can I just ask question and so
you've only built two out of the four on
site and so when you started the
business it was to build four and that
was to be the business but you've only
built two and before testing whether the
business works fully by building the
four you're trying to change it already
is there any particular reason why the
four never got built at restrictive cash
flows yeah so yeah be restricted for a
cash flow so we're just waiting until we
can actually get the next phase with the
tutelage is on site which should be
exactly the same exterior and there
might be a different layout for example
we've had requests if they want two
master bedrooms of either end for
example and so the layout can change
but the exterior and the size would be
exactly the same and that sold on a
99-year lease I saw if anyone's any
other questions counts I had how far are
you from the nearest village showing so
I just it's three and a half miles long
and so the center of population in fact
it's a mile away
that's where the puppies so these two
churches and so very closest at Mary's
Church on the site and then there's the
Free Church which is also so it's a very
there is a nursery I'm sorry there is a
nursery and for some the children yes
any other questions are talking no okay
thank you very much the ward members
councillor Daniel Pratt and he has sent
in an email and I'll just read that one
permission sought to allow two plots to
be used for permanent residential uses
acceptable in principle the planning
policy adopted by mid suffer District
Council since the change of use does not
amount to a new development or cause any
change to the character of the area to a
large extent I have no objection to the
proposal as there appears to be limited
arguments to suggest that the change
from recreational to permanent resident
residential use would cause unacceptable
harm the units offer the potential for
accommodation that uses renewable energy
and is less dependent on the National
Grid which is positive for sustainable
living however basis for parish councils
response to the proposal and the reasons
the app they write and the reasons
outlined in their objection should be
considered carefully the Parish Council
consent to the original application in
2017 on the basis that the development
of accommodation was support the
promotion
of tourism locally and in the county to
my understanding the original
application was permitted as a unit for
holiday purposes in the interests of
contributing to tourism and the economy
of the area providing custom for the
punchbowl community pub and the
employment of three local people in
their part-time capacity the development
would potentially cease to impart these
benefits following a change of use
further to this point it is possible the
decision to permit a change of use could
negatively impact support from the
parish councils for tourism developments
forthcoming therefore I feel that in the
case of approval of this application the
terms need to be set out for any future
developments on the site going forward
so members it had all the information
put before us and we've heard an
applicant we've heard from the ward
member it's really over us to discuss
and debate yeah councillor even thank
you very much um I've just got concerned
that we wouldn't ever approve the house
in this area you wouldn't approve
anything for residential use it's in a
beautiful area you know in a triple si
you know it's clear that people are
using it as a holiday destination and if
they're anglers you know the using the
lake and so on
so I've just got a concern we wouldn't
you know we wouldn't approve it for
residential use normally and if the
other lodges are being used for holiday
holiday use and clearly there was some
kind of business there that but not that
we can tell from from any business plan
we've got here yeah thank you very much
calcium Muller thank you I think my main
concern here relates to paragraph three
point one one on page three five a the
fact that in the past the planning
spectra have actually allowed
this sort of development but I find this
area quite confusing because we've got
other areas within this supper that are
quite controversial with so-called holy
lesser people have to move out for a
year and I just wonder this why I find
difficult make a decision on this
particular one based on that because
obviously if the planning inspector are
likely to allow it but I do agree with
what cows or Eber and say we wouldn't
normally allow a sort of residential
combination of built on this site can I
just ask maybe the officer just to touch
on the appeals from where that stands
and based on what councilor Burns said
you know where we would stand in terms
of if that was a route to go down you
know where would that take us so there's
been a variety of Appeal decisions
across the country about holiday light
versus residents release it has been
found to be a c3u so it is a residential
use so where we come to the particularly
mid suffolk decision is more helpful
which i've got here at is reference a
couple of points is what the inspector
was saying is whether or not the site's
appropriate location for permanent
residence development living conditions
and the tourism and leisure industry now
what she looked at in terms of the
location in this case this was just the
north of i airfield so it was very close
to i that it would be close proximity to
existing houses that it's while it's
some distance from facilities and
services they would access those local
services in i for example we go through
the other point and that they're also
saying that the units aren't there
therefore the change and the comparison
between you were there as a holiday or
you're there and you live there was
limited so i think the fact that we
don't have one of the units on site is
definitely an area of difference in
terms of the location if members wanted
to consider the differences between so
this site is just the north of my
airfield how long where and why you
access those services versus battered
food in essentially we have to consider
we have got this decision
does say yep you can use those holiday
lights for residential use does it
affect the access to services we can
consider that what about the living
conditions again we could consider that
I think primarily this point of view I
would say the main things
the main difference so we've got a unit
that's not on site it doesn't exist yes
they have consents to that but it would
amount to us quarantine kind of
commercial-free brand-new dwelling on
this site which I think Vince alluded to
not sure that would be something we
would generally support if they came in
with a planning application for any
house therefore that might be something
members want to discuss the fact that we
are losing the benefits that they
suggested would come in without evidence
whether that is something that's
concerned whether you'd like us to
review that and come back or if that's
sufficiently concerning that there would
be other ways you'd like to take that so
yes there are appeal decisions where we
have in a sense lost holiday lights and
I would say yes there are cases now
where if we've got a holiday let and
somebody applies and says great and when
changing to residential we are not going
to have argument against it I think
that's where the officers recommendation
has come from is that what are the
arguments and what I would say is we
need to think of the differences between
here and with I so yet the inspector was
saying very much that they would access
those local services yes they would be
by car but they would support them and
that they weren't convinced that the
loss will be harmful so it's again that
harm and if we were talking about the
benefit to the business would the loss
of those to the business be harmful I
think one of the arguments made of the
application was about business
diversification and the applicant
mentioned that as diversification how
the members feel that one okay hopefully
that helps because it's quite a lot of
decisions that wasn't particularly brief
hopefully it helps take just just to
summarize the the issue really is about
the fact that it's not actually built
out the fact that no business has
actually been running to justify in the
beginning on the initial application and
the accessibility to it to a to a to the
length of shops
aye aye vs. bath
but being taken in a resident rural area
so are they the three key points yeah I
think if we're talking about concerns
for that the officer we've got in the
new house in itself is a matter on its
own the fact that it was recently
developed they are the second unit and
whether that would be the loss of the
holiday unit in itself would it have a
impact on economic opportunities for the
tourist economy are given that was the
benefits put forward would it safe by
December for tourism also in terms of
facilities and services there is
obviously that difference between
tourism on residential so would members
have concerns about such a strong word
but schools and social infrastructure is
probably better we're fitting that and
obviously as I mentioned the fact that
all of these benefits were put forward
for the original application in terms of
supporting the angling Club supporting
local tourism economy supporting their
farm diversifying its business whether
they are issues that members feel way
one way or the other where we get to is
has it got benefits has it got adverse
impacts and which outweighs the other
thank you that helps a lot I think
accounts are welcome thank you Joe yeah
it does help a great deal and what I
have around in my head is we have got
two units on site which are perfectly
liveable in and they are holiday notes
we've got two concrete slabs if the
applicant were to put in an application
for housing development of those two
slabs using the design and everything
else as per the original application
would we be thinking would we be sitting
here thinking it was a good idea where
I'm coming from is I don't think that I
would be persuaded that to put that sort
of building on that slab and from the
outset saying it's going to be a
residential property paying presume
sell money and so on everything that
goes with residential development I
would not be comfortable with that
anyone else wish to come in cancer eben
do you want to pick up anything on the
points you've heard yeah anyone else
yeah yeah Thank You Chet so um it seems
to me this is a this application is a
speculative one based on the fact that
they've got a struggle with cash flow
and want to change the sort of terms of
what they originally intended to do and
whether or not that makes a great deal
of difference in the end to the amount
of money spent in the local pub I don't
know but it seems to me that were we to
allow this is in a sense allowing
residential development by the back door
I think you've summed that what we're
all thinking it's it's it's that's
exactly what I mean that's what it yeah
we would not allow houses in this site
if it was came forward four four houses
in that yard we would we would say no
straightaway or it wouldn't even come to
committee actually it would it's yeah it
would but this one would okay and so how
do we take this forward so is there
anyone that has a differing view to that
just so we know so we start heading in
one direction so I think Gemma I think
you I think the general view is that a
this wouldn't normally this would never
be allowed to come forward if it was in
this location and Keith was talking
about the tourism yeah so you know the
application was for to a tourist venue
and you're losing that tourism
to locate someone talked about that
being a mile away is a mile a mile away
from the yeah that's not that's not the
system yeah
is that sustainable yeah I think that's
that's the other question anything else
yeah
good it's not built out so can you
summarize that yeah just put a hold on
thank you few minutes
just to make your day the canteen is
shut due to it being too hot the air
conditionings backed up with the excess
eat from cooking with the outside
temperature so listen we're in no rush
because there's no lunch on you
and sorry it's fairly long because tried
to pick up on the various points and so
we talked about the holiday that and the
fact one's not been built so I hope I
picked up on that but if there's other
things members exchanged to have to do
so you wanted to refuse on the grounds
that the recently developed units in one
case and not having being constructed
would result in new residential
development in the countryside country
to see us one CS 2 FC 1 and F C 1.1
would not constitute a sustainable form
of development in the countryside and
that a lot of these permissive holiday
units would undermine the objective of
safeguarding economic opportunities for
the visitor and tourist economy of the
district evidence within the council's
visitor destination plan its which area
sector needs assessment 2017 and open
for business strategy contra to local
plan policies 811 and 1919 on this basis
the application would fail to
demonstrate that it would safeguard
sustainable rural tourism sector country
to MPP F paragraph 83 C rural housing
policies in paragraph 7778 with a new
dwelling also been contrary to
paragraphs 8 and 11 of the MPPs moreover
there is no evidence to demonstrate that
this would be a form of rural housing
which would be responsive to the local
circumstances reflect the local needs
nor enhance will maintain the vitality
of rural communities having regards the
application documentation and its
location poorly related to services and
facilities whereby occupants would be
expected to rely upon the private car to
access relevant infrastructure in
particular education health care and
community service on a regular basis not
equivalence the impacts identified with
the holiday units in addition the
proposal would result in the loss of
benefit from such units which were
identified as supports in the farm
business and diversifying its income
streams while supporting the angling
Club and other businesses in the area as
detailed in the supporting statements
the original application it has not been
demonstrated that the program would
continue to offer these or that the loss
would be outweighed by any benefits of
this proposal whilst residential use
would support services to some degree
this would not have the same benefits
with regard to the farm business and
going to open tourism business
specifically identified as benefiting
during the application furthermore given
the lack of sustainable access and
impact on infrastructure it is
considered that the proposal would have
adverse impact not outweighed by
benefits of country to the MPPs just
that cover what members were considering
just a little in view of what Gemma just
said I would therefore move refusal of
this application anyone else Jeff cancer
having it so anyone else wish to speak
first being proposed for refused by
Councillor that second in full refused
by cancer had they want on the grounds
that have been read out before us all
those on favor in favor of refusal of
the application for those reasons to
have a show of hands please
seven those against interest you don't
have to because you if you can't but if
you wish to abstain that's a separate
matter
yeah okay okay thank you very much so
that is refused okay members to thank
you very much
and there's no other no site visits no
other urgent business if you act as ask
you to take your cups with you when you
leave the chamber thank you very much
there is cool beans over the road don't
forget not sure i cool it'll be but